everybody hello hello madmondo thank you for the twitch prom
thank you thank you yes i'm working on sunday i made a
little bit of an oopsie i was like yay sunday rest day i'm
so tired and then i was like oh yeah let me go check when
these sponsors on twitch expire it should be the end of the
month.
I just gotta make sure.
And one of them is the end of the month, but the other one
was not.
In fact, the other one is about to expire in two hours.
I was just like, it's not the end of the month, so here I am
clocking in.
It's time to go back to work, Toki.
Back to work.
The crowd never stops.
all right it's okay i'm okay guys all right so my first one
all right let me see i have all of this back to the minds
you go dokey there's no no rest for you there's never rest
for you all right anyway yep yeah and i can only blame
myself i don't have a boss i i am my own boss.
So I'm just doing it to myself.
I'm overworking myself.
This was my own choice.
That's the worst part.
I'm on my own.
I am my own black company.
What are we gonna do?
My CEO abuses me, Makes me work on the Sunday.
The CEO is me.
Anyway, guys.
Let me look through the guidelines for this again.
All right, let's start this.
All right, enable.
Bam!
There we go.
It's popping up.
Sorry to the people who are mobile, but you cannot hide this
overlay.
Just like an FYI.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let me read through this.
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
Alright, this stream is sponsored by How to Make a Killing.
It will be in theaters on February 20th.
And you can get your tickets now.
Yes, it's been playing since Actually, it is.
Yeah, it's February 22nd.
So you technically watch this movie right now, your friends.
It stars Glenn Powell, Margaret Qualley, Zach Woods, Tofer
Grace, and Ed Harris.
Oh, I know I recognize Ed Harris.
It's suspenseful, entertaining, intense, and action-packed.
It's apparently a darkly comedic thriller.
All right, let's check this film.
Let's check this trailer out, guys.
Let me, let's see.
I have pulled it up.
the trailer yet so we'll we'll watch this together beckett
oh it's by age 24 wow so are you living in the city now a
little outside of it whatever happened to the red fellow
fortune yeah what happened oh i murdered it someday there
were seven of them there were seven of them okay seven awful
people you're still poor ass off between myself and 28
billion dollars oh that's a A lot of money.
I'm back here.
Oh, so it's like a battle royale.
Was it that easy?
With just seven people.
Pop, pop.
Been occupied.
With what?
Occupations.
Well, call me when you've killed them all.
How to make a killing.
All right.
Since then, there's February 20th.
It looks interesting honestly the whole concept of like of
like a miniature battle royale But yes, this will be in
theaters on February 20th You can grab your tickets now how
to make a kill him from Glenn Poell, Margaret Qualley, Zach
Woods, Tofer Grace and Ed Harris.
Yay All right now and you figure out what to do next
okay all right let's guys let's figure out what to do next
guys we have an hour there's another one i have another one
too because um no i can't i can't i'm not i'm i'm obligated
to stay up for another hour uh there's i i had nope other
plans What should we do for the next hour?
And then after that, we have another one that we have to do,
too.
Mugenics?
I guess we could try.
Oh, no.
I want to play something more brain empty, guys.
I am...
I really...
The only issue right now, guys, is that I really do not want
to think at the moment.
I'm so, I am so brain dead.
Like on Sunday, I, it's a Sunday right now.
And like, I'm usually, usually I'm never thinking, but you
don't understand.
Usually I would have like at least one IQ during stream
days.
But on Sunday, there was like that one IQ, that one brain
cell is like, that's checked out.
Like he's on a, he's on a resort right now.
So I really cannot be thinking today.
All right.
Yeah, he's on a weekly vacation, basically, at a resort.
It's his time.
All right, let's see.
I'm going to look through.
There are some games I want to check out.
I'm like, are they good one-off games?
Oh, yeah.
Also, my condolences.
to Canada right now for those who don't keep up with the
Olympics because who actually keeps up with the winter
Olympics not gonna lie I feel like okay this I feel like the
popular I feel like when we're talking about Olympics
everyone usually talks about the summer Olympics versus the
winter Olympics so like but unfortunately there has it's a
sad day for Canada because the only about or like care about
we got second place and of course the country that beat us
was unfortunately to us america usa usa what the fuck is a
kilometer ah
so like like to Canadians to be fair i don't keep up with
hockey i'm actually the one person of that do not tell the
other Canadians about this because I'm scared they'll
they'll shred my passport but I actually I don't care much
about hockey I don't care much about sports on ice so so but
please do not tell the Canadian Canadians about this what's
that Peter Griffin quote where he's like I don't care much
about.
I don't care for the Godfather.
I did not care for hockey.
Clip this and get her the board.
But I just never cared much about any type of sport that's
related to it being on ice.
The one thing that actually got me about hockey.
Was he the rivalry?
Oh, and Yuri on Ice.
But that was just like a little...
I didn't really care much about Yuri on Ice.
I only watched like one episode.
But then my entire Tumblr feed was about Yuri.
A lot of people did care about Yuri on Ice.
But I wasn't one of them.
I was just like, oh, the animation is really pretty.
And the opening was really good.
heard the opening of Yuri on ice is actually really fucking
good.
And that's like the only thing I liked about it.
Um, I was not like, you know, I'm reformed, but I wasn't on
that side.
What kind of fujo?
I had a set of particular tastes.
Okay.
My fujo-ness was not in, other than for death note, um,
majority of what I, what I shipped was not in anime that's
that's all i'll say like the one exception was def no
because it was the first anime i've ever watched yeah i am
reformed though i got you guys have to listen to the opening
is actually was it the was it the opening or the ending
theme let me check i need to make sure my oh yeah it's
history maker i really enjoyed history maker History maker
was...
Was...
Be...
Bum...
It is very gay though.
Like...
Bum...
Oh, and also...
Okay.
I also really...
I did not care much about free as well.
For those who are like the...
There was a...
For those who did not keep up with that...
Um...
That era of anime, there was a specific era of anime where
there was, it was basically like really, uh, I would say
gay, gay baiting.
But like Yuri on Ice, they like, they, they, they committed
to it.
Not baiting.
They didn't bait at the end.
They actually like, were like, it's real at the very end.
But Free, Free was, was like full on just baiting people.
like free was actually full-on baiting um and a lot there
was a lot of people were obsessed with it I didn't care much
about free but like but like I said there was a particular
era of sports uh where of anime where at one point okay when
was Yuri on ice it was literally like that era where every
sport anime was like full-on gay baiting
yeah ground like okay what about free free was anime okay
yurion nice was 2016 free was you know what since we're here
i might as well since we're here i might as well be on a
chatting screen um where the fuck is the area like i'm here
anyway oh that doesn't fit right i only fits actually not
here where the fuck is the school one
uh let's see there you go school chatting there we go oh
yeah i don't have like twitch chat here apparently that's
bad there we go all right here we go all right so where's
the music too god i'm all over the place all right anyway
yeah i forgot i should just i i have not yet set up Free.
When the fuck- Wait, free anime swimming.
Oh my god, you can't even like Google this anime.
You have to like be so specific.
All right, free is- was released on 2013.
All right, so in the around the 2010s to mid-20, 2015, the
sport Yowie tier list went.
The thing is, I only know three.
And I know like some people would- Haiku.
I never watched that one, but I've heard a lot of things.
about it.
I mean, there were a lot of men in there, so any ship was
possible.
Free and Yuri on Ice, those are the three, oh, those are the
three ones that I know.
Oh, yeah, there's slime dunk.
I forgot about slime dunk.
Yeah, no.
Free was so, it was just wild.
But then apparently the writers were like, they're 100%
straight and I'm like sure they are um they're very adamant
that they're like none of these boys are gay and I'm like
sure they sure but have you ever seen the opening let me
show you guys the open and the ending by the way um that's
why actually one of my favorite songs um who is the one kejo
kejo's fucking fire by the way oh yeah sorry that's the
ending where's the opening the opening was pretty good too
this one too this one's actually it's all the ending all
right that those the songs are fire don't you they're just
bros being bros you're right i'm sorry god god treat your
homies right am i We gotta treat the homies right, guys.
A storyteller.
You wouldn't get it, Doki.
You're not true, bro.
Storyteller.
Thank you for the 1,500 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, everyone.
Please have a great day and pause the vibes.
Doki, please remember to self-care and drink some water.
Of course, thank you.
Thank you for the reminder.
I'll go hydrate right now.
Thank you for the bitties.
Thank you.
It's a good song.
It's a good ass song Always gotta kiss the homies good
night, you know Gotta make sure they're safe Yeah, no, the
ending I told you Both free endings are really good But
that's the only thing I liked about the show I was like I
had a friend I'm a friend who was like core fujo like
basically like all genres were not safe like everything she
touches there was at least one couple that she must ship and
because we followed we were mutuals on tumblr so my entire
tumblr feed was literally like ship art or like ship porn uh
from free and um uriana is because she was crazy obsessed
with both of the shows um and also other shows too but those
two were one of their top two shows at that time when it was
like super popular um and then i was just reblogging like
transformer shit like i like i would just reblog like i
would okay look to be fair i will say what i did say this
before but one of the ships was that i liked was like any
universe of Sherlock and Watson.
But that's OG shit, guys.
That's like, that's timeless, you know?
Like, since the beginning of the inception of Sherlock, ye
old Victorian ladies were shipping Sherlock and Watson.
Like, it was truly, it is endless.
It never dies.
Like, it's timeless, guys.
They're OG for a reason.
And it works for every generation.
It is a classic.
It aged like fine wine.
So I would like any type of universe of Sherlock and Watson.
And I would be like, yes.
Robert Downey Jr. version with Jude Law.
Yes.
uh a bendy legs cabbage patch man with martin freeman yes uh
ye old victorian sherlock and watson from the books by
andrew co was his phone name andrew something so it's
sherlock right it's been a while since i read sherlock all
right i was like arthur arthur conan doyle yes that's like
Andrew i remember it started with an a We don't talk about
the real Pharaoh version.
I almost forgot that was a thing.
I actually deleted it from my head.
Yeah, Sir Andrew.
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle from back then.
Elementary with Lucy.
Okay, there was a really controversial time back then on
Tumblr when Elementary came up because Sherlock was also...
By the way, I will say, Sherlock did not age very well as a
show.
when you re-watch that show as you're, I would say Sherlock,
the show was the perfect time for tweens and teenagers and
pre-teens.
Yeah, pre-teens and teenagers for Sherlock or because
because as you get older, you realize the writing for
Sherlock was sort of ass.
Because you're like, I need to get into my mind palace.
And then you're just like, oh my God.
Why did I thought that was so cool?
Like, when Joe's like, quiet, I'm going to go into my mind
palace.
And then it's like, he's like, oh, oh.
And then like words.
And then back then I was like, oh my God, that's so cool.
And oh my God, he's so smart.
fiction though anyway anyway um but i would say season one
was the best version of sherlock um and then after that it
all went downhill it's written by same people who wrote um
who wrote what is it called oh fuck i'm pretty sure it was
by him right i'm gonna read i'm gonna read i'm want to look
at this.
Uh, I knew he wrote some, he wrote like stuff I didn't like,
because like, they were like, oh yeah, that's like how he
writes stuff.
Like, he's known to, he, oh yeah, like, like, first season
is good and then, like, after that it goes downhill.
Like, that was, like, Stephen Moffat and Mark Gatis.
Yeah, he's like, he, like, at first the show gets real, it's
good, and then it goes downhill from there.
He doesn't go well over time.
But my main issue was like season after season one it just
sucks because like they wrote themselves in the corner for
some things that they did when they killed out moriati and
be like how do we fake sherlock's death and everyone came up
with like amazing theories and then each season took like
two to five years to make um and and like when the actual
solution to what they thought of On how Sherlock faked his
death.
It was so fucking stupid.
That I was just like, that's it.
Like, that's how they do it.
That's, that's it.
Anyway, season one was the best version of Sherlock.
But it did not age very well.
And rewatched a couple of, I didn't say, I won't say like a
couple, I won't say the episodes.
But I saw several clips.
I saw several clips recently.
from the original from Sherlock season one and I was like oh
my god
oh my god I thought this was so cool like oh and it's very
gay too it is very gay they did a lot of gay bathing as well
because the writers one of the writers was gay so I mean is
by the way he didn't stop being gay but one of the right one
of the co-creators is gay so he knew how to like put off the
sexual tension there um but then you're like yeah no they're
they're they're like not gay i'm like sure they are uh
Anyway, totally not Okay, anyway Yes, and House and Wilson
Yes, that I knew I was forgetting I was forgetting one more
iteration Yes, and also House and Wilson I too shipped those
two Other than that, someone mentioned elementary Anyway, so
back in the Tumblr days There was a Tumblr war in the
Sherlock fandom between Sherlock and elementary, of course,
I sided with the Sherlock side because they were like, oh,
wow, you're just trying to copy Sherlock.
You're a cheap inferior version of the superior British
original Sherlock.
I didn't really participate in it.
I just liked the post where people were making fun of
elementary because I was also part problem because I was
like, oh, Sherlock as a woman, how would this affect my
fujo?
My fujo-ness.
Like, I can't ship Sherlock with Watson if she's a woman.
Like, it doesn't make sense in my head.
It truly, I can't fujo shit.
I know.
I was just like i can't fujo ship a woman that doesn't make
any sense like you know how like back when back then they're
like i hate this woman because it interferes with my with my
with my fujo ships like
how dare she cock block this true love that's happening
right now how dare machinery it's like when um i didn't pay
much attention uh to um anime fujo shipping like i said i
was a different type of fujo back then i'm reformed by the
way i am very much reformed um history thank you for the
tier one sub to fujo um and yeah female ex-mouth the
forbidden chip
basically similar to how people hated sakura i i think
that's her name because it it like was interfering with the
naruto slash saseke uh ships that's basically how the minds
of a fujo works they're like i hate her because she is in
the way for my one true pairing like okay but true though
It's basically, that's how the minds of a fusion work.
It doesn't matter, like, who the character is.
As if they, if it's a woman that's interfering with their
one true pairing, they'll be like, I hate you.
It doesn't matter if she's, like, actually important or,
like, she's a very likable character.
She gets in the way of my one true pairing.
I fucking hate you.
You are the worst.
The worst character ever developed Or made by the creator I
fucking hate you But that's how the mind works A silver mind
Thank you for the Twitch Prime Thank you thank you So a
little A little lesson basically For anyone who's Who Does
understand the minds of a Fuzhou Anyway I am reformed now My
My brain has been re-educated.
I'm not like that anymore, guys.
Yeah, Fujo Lesson 101, 101.
How does a Fujo think?
I am not like that anymore.
My brain has restructured itself.
sure don't you sure why lie to us all right
um anyway okay wait let me double check something real quick
uh still have oh my god i've only been oh my god i didn't
even realize i've only been like uh oh my god 30 minutes
have passed where did the time go
Where did the time go?
I didn't even realize 30 minutes have already passed.
All right.
Let's figure out what to do, guys.
Thank God I'm on Twitch.
And also, it's Sunday.
So this is going to be like all over the place today.
My mind is not, it's not there.
My mind, where is my mind?
No, this is, we are going to be doing rivals.
a bounty for rivals too so we gotta wait another 30 minutes
before i can take that bounty all right let me you know
let's go dumpster diving on steam or some let's let's let's
explore let's explore steam right now and see any there's
anything interesting going on
um the fishing fps game what fishing fps game no it's just
the other one it's just this and this rival rivals and then
we should be good i just want to play like whatever honestly
all right new releases fish hunters is there actually a fish
game fish hunters little fishing game.
It has mixed reviews.
I do not.
Oh, the new Chilla Arts game.
No, I'm good.
Sorry, Mo.
I'm alright.
You guys know High on Life 2 came out?
Do you guys know it?
I felt like it was like Shadow Dropped.
I've been, I've actually been a Patreon since that time I
joked about what if I became a Patreon?
For Chilla Arts.
I've never stopped.
Like, even when they were on a break.
I continue to support.
You never forget.
Always support your small indie developers.
Yeah, I'm still on the Patreon.
I'm still...
That's why I'm in the games.
I also need to, like, send them new assets.
Because I keep forgetting to.
I keep forgetting that, like...
the update um yeah i'm just i'm dedicated to the uh uh
what's the word i'm
i'm dedicated to the to the meme right now to the bit it was
a it was a bit and i'm like i'm too far in now i'm too far
into this bit i can't stop
I'm far too gone into it I'm way too committed now
Let's see I'm looking through it There is it I'm going all
in Yeah Oh yeah but like I said There is a new high on life
I was planning on playing the first high on life game When I
was free Lunar Snow has a fort Yeah but it's ass If it was
like With the ride style didn't be pretty decent but the
lunar snow fortnite skin is so ass like i didn't even i was
just like bro it looks so fucking bad it does not look good
they made it like i guess they made it like a fortnite style
like the the fortnite art style but it just doesn't work
especially for the hair i wish the hair was more like the
rival's hair
ass.
Man, like, I didn't even realize how On Life 2 came out.
Like, it has mixed reviews, though, so I assume it was not
that good.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
I don't know.
I'm looking through uh, I'm looking through Steam right now.
Oh, yeah.
I heard solo leveling is now in Fortnite, and it was so
fucking funny because, what's his name?
Uh, Nick, uh, the the Nick guy was like, yeah, Like he got
early access to fort to the newest season for fortnight was
with the solo leveling skin It was so fucking funny because
like people were saying like he's just making up the plot He
was like making up his own story about what solo leveling is
Like if you were like wait that's that's not the plot yeah
he made up the lore for those Oh, yeah, I love solo
leveling.
Anyway, this is what happens to solo leveling.
And he was actually larping.
Yeah, for those who want to see the tweet.
It was like, and you were like, this anime is so boring.
You got to make up your own story for it.
It was making like random head cannons.
Yeah, whatever he made of is probably...
How did solo...
I've never...
I've never watched or read solo leveling.
how the fuck did like it gained the popularity that it did
if it is that ass like I don't understand like is it a meme
that is ass or like is it truly ass like oh it's just hype
moments and aura farming there's no plot oh so just the
animation itself is really really good yeah is it just the
Oh, no plot.
Oh, that's why.
It's just literally all like fighting animation.
I mean, like, like, I guess like some people just enjoy
that.
Like, yeah.
Some people just want to see like pretty colors.
Okay, but which is worse?
Sword art online or solo leveling?
Or am I, like, or am I insulting anyone for even trying to
compare the two?
The God's gift of Earth to solo level.
Solo, I knew it.
How fucking dare you.
Both are weak.
Sword art online at least tries.
Okay, well, that's sort of debatable depending on, like, who
you ask.
Yeah, I was going to say, am I over?
Opening a new can of worms for introducing sword art online
into this mix into this debate It really depends on who you
ask does it
I have watched the first three episodes of sword on sword
art online and I've was I was at conventions where sword art
online was at its peak and it was fucking everywhere.
I was there.
I've seen I've seen how hyped it was by everybody.
But I think Sword Art Online introduced the because it was
so popular my biggest gripe about Sword Art Online was that
it opened it opened the gates to so many mid mid Isakai, uh,
animas.
That's, that's a big, sorry, a big gate to a lot of mid or
incredibly ass Isakai animas because of how fucking popular
it was.
So that's like my biggest gripe about Sword Hard Online
because it was, a lot of them were quite mid.
Sword Hard Online is not an Isakai.
That's also very debatable.
it did sort of a huge damage.
to the industry.
True.
I was going to say.
Oh, that's sort of...
That's debatable.
Boofy, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Oh, we had a good stream.
No, thank you, but to your wife's sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Not everything is easy, God.
There we go.
in a good stream we are just talking about sword art online
and and the pros and cons of what it did to add the
animation industry sword
art online is a lesser what's dot hack let's see i might
reckon i might know it from just seeing the the pic actually
i don't know it i was like i might screenshots.
I was like, I, I don't recognize this at all.
I don't know what this is.
Damn, we have a lot of opinions about anime here.
Bum, bum, bum.
All right, let me go back to, all right, let's see.
I'm going back to steam, steam dumpster diving right now.
See what we can check out.
There was one thing I wanted to play, but like, actually, I
think I could play by myself.
It is multiplayer, but I wanted to try.
I just wanted to, I just wanted to see what it's, check it
out myself.
It's called Keep Gambling.
And it's literally just Scratch and Win simulator.
I got Scratch that itch of mine.
I was obsessed with Scratch and Win, but this is why I don't
gamble in real life.
Because like, I was so obsessed over it.
I was little, which you might be wondering, how are you
purchasing these scratch and wind tickets when you were
little?
Well, I was enabled by my parents.
Because my parents love, like whenever we go grocery
shopping or we're at like a convenience store, they would
sometimes buy one scratch and wind ticket where like, you
know, they're like the gold mines or I don't remember the
one I remember the most is the gold mine ones so um and they
would always be like oh doky scratch for me uh for good luck
and then so I got obsessed over them so every time we're at
like a convenience store grocery shopping um I'd be like can
we buy because they're like one dollar two dollars or
something I'm like can we buy one and I would just be like
scratching them instantly because I love doing it and like I
only I never and then I try to buy it myself you know and
they're like you're too young for that you're supposed to be
18 and then I was like a seven-year-old kid trying to buy
scratch it's bad it's bad they started they they started off
young yeah they try to start me off young with that uh
Yeah, so, so I don't, um, yeah, that got a head start.
My first app gotcha.
So, um, obviously when I turned 18, I didn't buy my own
scratch and win tickets.
Because also I didn't really, I didn't know how.
And I felt, I was like, oh, I felt like it would be weird
asking.
At that time, I was just like, oh, I feel weird not buying
it without parental supervision.
after that but i gotta get that itch does come back
sometimes anyway let's do some virtual scratch and win
tickets i was like oh my gosh what if it's still illegal if
i buy this with parental supervision watching me scratch
but i was obsessed over it when i was growing up it did not
help that my mom enabled me mom but my dad too that my
parents just thought it was fun to see me scratch them
all right i never done lottery tickets though because i feel
like like you gotta think about think for your own numbers
and i thought that's too much work like give me a coin i'll
just fucking scratch some lot of like do scratch the tickets
like that's too much work thinking for your own numbers
Yeah, that's too hard.
So that's why it hasn't got me.
You know, like, the ones that do get me are the easy ones.
You're like opening blind boxes.
You just open the box and stuff like that.
It's like opening loot boxes.
That's easy.
Now I have to use my own brain to think of numbers.
Now that's fine.
I'm okay.
That's too much effort.
Let's try this game out.
let's see bump bump but um all right this is keep gambling
see where is it you scratch and win simulator oh my god
forgot to wait fuck I forgot to grab my I more cough drops
god damn it all right let's see i hope it's not too loud all
right let's see
options no motion blur need let's see okay maybe i don't
need that much frame i don't need that much fps i think we
should be good all right let's go
I'm here to scratch my tickets.
All right, character select.
All right.
Oh, shit.
America in celebration of...
In celebration of America winning...
Getting first place in hockey today.
No timers, no debt.
Just be your gambling.
I'm not gambling alone to pay.
All right, let's pay off my debts.
God bless America, I say it.
I gotta play both sides, guys.
So at least I can win in something.
All right.
Repay your debt.
Oh, shit.
If I play both sides, I'm always winning.
You'll never lose.
All right.
How do I buy tickets?
hello i would like to buy brick up please how do i buy it
okay f uh oh my god don't have enough money no okay all
right it's time to scratch okay 27 oh oh two ones oh one
another one two twenty ones come on no however the urge to
gamble traps you okay i'm back i'm back but i don't
understand what happened to me wait how do i gamble oh it's
over here i see the 711 wait that's the casino right i can
walk past this oh my god i got too excited Okay, that's
slots, but I want to scratch and win.
Oh, shit.
I forgot to change my category.
Give me a sec.
It's called just just gamble.
Wait, what is the game called?
Oh, keep gambling.
There we go.
Just gamble.
Sorry, keep gambling.
Alright.
Where is it?
Oh my god, it's so...
That's what it's called.
It's nine.
Okay.
It'll be fine.
Alright.
Where is...
Can I still scratch?
Can I still scratch and win?
Oh, that is.
Take it fully.
Scratch that.
Did I win anything?
Sir, did I...
Did I...
Did I win anything?
No.
it's three of a con right oh no wait i don't have money how
do i what do i what can i do oh wait my atm i must have
money in my atm right wait i can buy this okay that's enough
okay i can scratch this oh shit okay
I gotta calm down.
Oh, I had to scratch.
Oh God, maybe I gotta stop.
I gotta calm down.
Oh my God.
Um, um, drop.
Am I okay?
Oh my God.
How do I stop?
Why is my heart still?
Why?
How do I calm down?
I don't understand.
I just want to scratch and win.
Oh, am I lagging a little bit?
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Is it fully scratched?
Did I win?
Oh, wait, no, that's the other one.
Wait, where's the other one?
Oh, here it is.
$100.
Alright.
scratch the cash okay it's fine that's that's nothing but I
do have another one I'm gonna scratch it but I scratch it
slowly I won't freak out as much I think oh $2.25 it's fine
it's fine I still have more
okay I can still buy more cards too more scratches Oh my
god, whoops.
Oh my god, the controllers are...
Like, I know there's only two controllers, but...
Oh, $5?
Oh my god.
It's fine, that's fine.
Wait, discoverer...
Wait, can I not cash this in?
Yeah.
That's $5.
Yeah!
Wait, there's something I can cash this?
Yeah, $3!
Oh my god, I thought these were duds.
Wow, I was wrong.
Oh, that was a dud.
Never mind.
Alright, let's crash this.
Come on.
Oh, $1?
Oh, $2?
Oh, $3!
Money is money!
Alright.
Yeah.
Money is money, guys.
Three whole dollars.
Yeah, that's fine.
So I can always buy...
Wait, I can buy a raw cherry double.
That's a $10.
But, like, imagine if I win, like, $20 from this.
Guys, imagine.
$5, $10, $5.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's okay.
I still have...
that's okay i can win it back with this that's okay i can
win back all my money with this
okay but but but just imagine just imagine if i just scratch
this and just win it all back just imagine guys wait cash in
my first ticket wait where's my first ticket i already
cashed oh my god i forgot about this oh my god i forgot okay
okay it's okay Oh my god, where's the other one that I
dropped?
Oh!
That's so much money.
Wait, okay, I need to make $50.
Okay.
Okay, $1.
Look, guys, I made it back.
I literally made back my money.
Okay.
I bet I can make it back again.
Oh, look at that!
It's like spinning a wheel for another free turn.
I spun a wheel I got another free turn, guys Let's go
gambling Oh, oh Spin a wheel for another free turn Look at
that, another re-roll
Oh my god, it's so easy Wait, gambling is so easy
Okay Alright, another free turn We got how many free rolls
can I get oh my god another free roll okay 10
oh my god two two free rolls two free rolls
okay all right don't worry I scratched it this time I just
got too excited you know
okay two full dollars guys dollars.
Now let's Oh!
Okay, another free roll.
And another one.
Oh my god, wait.
I... I'm so close.
I'm so close to paying off my debts.
And another free roll.
And another one.
Don't worry, don't worry.
It's gonna lead up to a big roll.
Guys, thank God.
Thank God I won two rolls earlier.
Oh my god, whoops.
It's leading up.
This all builds up, guys.
It's all gonna build up to a big jackpot.
You don't understand.
I'm increasing my rates.
Okay, go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
One dollar.
Okay, I need to drink a...
Oh my god, I need to lower my heart rate.
how do I lower my heart rate I'm gonna die plus heart rate
what calms you down oh my god well I gotta buy a big ticket
I'll get him okay don't worry
well I can continue it's okay ten dollars oh I told you big
ticket oh my god what am I doing doing the small items I
like how you're like you're supposed to pay off your debts i
was like no i'm just gonna keep gambling i'm just i was like
the original fuck the game i was gonna keep scratching and
winning
we don't need no timer we just gotta keep scratching this is
a lucky ticket guys right here this right here
oh two dollars Pearls?
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
We made back $2, though.
There's more than just scratches.
But you don't understand.
I'm winning, though.
I'm winning.
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, my God, $20.
Oh, $1?
Oh, my God, my lottery?
Oh, my God.
$20?
I got $20?
Oh my gosh, are there anything that calms me down?
Where's minus heart?
Why would I want more heart rate?
Oh, minus heart rate.
Okay.
I'll buy this.
What?
Okay.
I'm okay.
Okay, I'm so calm now.
I am so calm.
I'm so calm to do more gambling.
Okay.
Oh, five?
Six?
Another five?
I made back my money.
I literally made it all back.
But, just got that.
I'm gonna buy a big ticket item.
I can afford this now.
I'm...
Whoa.
I've earned this.
Okay.
Oh, what's that?
One whole dollar?
Oh, $50?
okay okay that's fine that's fine that's fine i think i can
you know what i deserve this i'm making bank right now oh
okay you know i deserve two you know i've been doing a good
job
i didn't even do a really good job oh what two dollars 15 oh
my god i'm raining in money
I mean, this costs $25, but like $20 whole dollars!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I'm winning way too much.
Is that?
Oh, my God.
That's $5 whole dollars.
I can buy more drinks from this.
Okay, I need to lower my heart rate again.
Okay.
There you go.
Alright, we gotta do the smaller ones again.
okay oh no no my scratch let's see 15 okay i made a five
dollar profit and then all right i gotta i gotta look at
this for good luck scratch time oh that's fine that's fine
not everyone can be winners it's okay one one One failed
ticket.
Doesn't hurt anybody.
Not everyone can be winners.
Okay.
One dollar.
Come on.
Come here.
Give me here.
It's okay.
Everyone hits their slump.
You know?
Everyone hits their slumps, guys.
It happens.
We just gotta start low.
And then we can hit big later.
You hit your slump.
And then you go back to winning.
Can't win all the time, guys.
Oh, look at that.
Two whole dollars.
It's coming back.
It's coming back, guys.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
It's a real experience.
Increases the throw more when you're extra broke.
There's no risk involved when you're living too comfortably
in life.
You gotta increase the odds.
Oh, look at that!
$20!
I doubled, I practically doubled my money right here.
Okay.
I keep pressing right click for some reason.
I don't know, it just, it makes me want to like, like zoom
in with right click, you know?
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, $2.00?
That means I could buy two more of the $1 tickets?
Oh my god, I keep, oh my god, I keep accidentally buying
more.
Yeah, sure, Doki, an accident.
Yeah, you accidentally keep buying more.
Just stop.
But what if I miss out on winning?
You don't know that.
If I'd stop, I won't get the mine full of diamonds.
wait there's a house you can do csgo crate openings i've
never done one before my life maybe maybe it's time to start
maybe it's finally the right time to start
all right we're oh is it that one the video game one on the
right side i assume it's that one i'm gonna head over there
oh yeah that's a cardiac arrest right there
all right how do i get can i steal a car to get there or do
i have my own car no i don't all right i can walk past this
don't get there get there i'm gonna i see some crates my
name on it.
I can cross the road.
So you look at that.
It's like Frogger.
Oh my god.
It's not like Frogger.
Okay.
That was close.
I saw the car started swirling.
And I knew it was not like Frogger.
Okay.
Why don't I get to the other side?
Okay, like that.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Why would you put an invisible wall there?
Why would you take this away from me?
Okay, here.
Okay, that must be where the teenager lives.
This must be it.
Where is it?
Where's this PC?
Oh my god, there it is.
It's time!
Okay.
Store.
Oh my god, I have just enough.
Just enough.
Alright!
Knife!
No!
I'm a dollar short!
I earned my money now!
Oh, no.
I thought if I go all in, it'll work out.
No knife for you.
That was all my money.
What do you mean going all in didn't work?
That's it.
I have nothing to live for.
all right nice i got five dollars yet guys guys it's okay i
got back my money i got five dollars time to go to a casino
i actually never went to a casino before i was every time
like i have a chance to go to a casino i was just too young
and i never like and also like um i just find like actual
slots machine like pretty boring please never go all right
now i can virtually go to a stop machine all right oh whoops
i'm spinning oh gonna spin again how the fuck do you win in
these i heard like las vegas is slowly like um oh no i'm
broke oh no i did not win a single oh my god no i'm gonna
get cardiac oh no i'm gonna get cardiac arrest again no i'll
take my i'll end on my own terms no okay there you go yeah
yeah i heard like i heard casinos like a lot of like places
in las vegas is starting to go out of business because no
one's going to Las Vegas anymore to Gamba.
Alright, it's fine.
We can try again.
I think the only one I've been winning on is literally
scratch cards.
The scratch and win.
It's okay.
Just gotta try again.
I still wanna go to like the freaky store art exhibit place.
That place looks so cool.
why is there a strip club in my casino hello I have no time
to be looking at strippers oh my god none of them were
winners how is that possible how
I live in the casino I got the casino has the worst rates it
really has the worst rates
nobody gambles anymore that's why Konami is focusing more on
games again I just thought they ran out of IPs so they gotta
create new IPs so they can make more puchinko games off of
their new IPs also I don't think we need epic guys I
realized maybe high
if you're under a hundred dollars you'll never win that's
Fucked.
Okay.
I know what to do.
We're going to scratch and win until we get $50 and then we
open cases.
That's the strat.
Oh, higher heart rate means bigger.
Oh, is that why you have to have high heart rates?
Okay.
Higher heart rate.
I'm going to test this area.
Okay.
We gotta do this before.
There you go.
Oops, I accidentally bought another ticket.
Oh my god!
Scan it, scan it, scan it!
Okay, okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're fine!
I'm so calm!
So calm!
There you go.
Oh my god, another five dollars.
Oh my god, I'm playing with fire right now.
Oh my god, they were right.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my God.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, you have five under.
I'm calm.
I'm so calm.
Yeah, everything is, it's okay.
It's okay.
We're so calm right now.
Oh.
four dollars four whole dollars what i think oh i think we
can do this this heart rate what the oh okay all right
that's more money so i'm gonna preemptively buy this just in
case i'm just just in case if something happens if something
happens At least it's right next to me.
All right, I'm buying the $10 one.
I'm feeling lucky tonight.
Oh, I want my money back.
All right.
That's good.
I want it all back.
That's another free roll.
It's technically a free roll.
Okay.
there we go there we go i can keep on scratching guys i can
i can keep on scratching all right
okay all right and buy another ten dollar
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god with this okay okay
i gotta look i might i gotta look okay oh my god oh my god i
gotta look both sides before crossing the road.
Oh, my God.
I forgot to buy.
Oh, it's okay, okay.
I can.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
I forgot, I realized, I forgot to buy more energy drinks,
but that's okay.
That's okay.
I have 100.
I have 100 heart rate.
Oh, it's too late.
I'm committed.
I'm so committed to this.
I might be able to open, like, three crates before I get a
heart attack.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
Maybe gamers always...
Alright, gamers always care.
Okay, there you go.
CC, I told you.
Okay, that...
I forgot.
Gamers do not bring healthy drinks.
Gamers do not buy healthy drinks.
It's all about the...
It's all about the Mountain Dew and the Coca-Cola's.
Wait.
okay we're gonna put this here and drink this when we can
okay all right okay come on oh sell unbox that's a purple
that's an herbal item all right that's fine we can keep
unboxing all right we're gonna get a knife we're gonna get a
knife here I have enough money to this.
The thrill.
Oh my god.
Another purple.
Let's go.
We made it back.
We made back our money.
Oh my god.
Is that a pink right there?
I'm seeing all the rain.
It's raining.
It's raining guns.
Also apparently.
I know I said this before.
But it's cheaper to buy a gun than this to buy a ram right
now.
Um,
okay, I, I need a, okay, wait, I need to drink this.
Okay, that's fine.
I can still play.
Alright, it's okay.
I can keep unboxing.
It's alright.
It's alright, I have plenty of money.
I have plenty of money to go.
go around for this.
Oh!
Yes!
I told you!
I told you I made it back!
I made it all back.
Okay, we can do again.
Oh my god, it's all might work back.
Huge money.
Huge fucking money.
Are there knives in this game?
What?
Are there knives in this game mode?
Or is it just reds?
guys guys I need a no I need a no guys never stop never stop
until you hit the big big ticket items big bills big dollar
bills only one way to find out oh my god there are knives
okay I do not see it though I do not see the knives lying i
saw a lot of them i don't i see the pink and the red but
where the fuck are the knives got mac 10 engraved oh another
one oh my god oh i'm just a natural oh my god hey it's a
fish
heart rate up to a near cardiac arrest.
I might just be a natural, guys.
I can't stop.
Now you're right.
You're so right.
Why did I stop?
That means the knife is like literally at the tip of my
fingertips right now.
Tip of my fingers.
Knife is just there.
I was going to go to a casino after this with all my sweet
winnings.
Oh!
My god to fucking easy Holy shit to fucking easy Now I gotta
go to casino next I cash in my winnings at the casino Oh god
We gotta make it there we gotta make it to the casino first
guys We got...
All right.
Gotta make sure I don't die.
Die before I can hit the slots.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I have 100 BPM before I get cardiac arrest.
Gang, there is also a gamble.
That's true.
all right maybe they have oh there they do they do they do
we're fine we're fine watch this
yeah easy i don't think i won anything i think i've lost
every rule
oh my god did i win any money i don't even know i've just
been pressing buttons surely one of them is a big winner
oh I have okay nice this is a cheat guys oh my god oh my god
I got it I got it I gotta drink this real quick I got scared
I got really scared
okay if I make back I can make it back Guys, I think I
fucked up by Guys, I fucked up I fucked up by having a low
heart rate No!
This casino is a scam
See, I think you with the rain, think you think What's the
point?
What's the fucking point where I could just open crates Open
crates and do my scratches Say it ain't so who would have
thought gotta do it a traditional way gotta do your scratch
tickets and crates that's how it goes whoa what it turned no
wait 500 i saw money i saw i made for the slot what do you
mean It fucking, this is a fucking parking lot.
Oh my god, they turned.
They can turn to the parking lot.
How the fuck was I supposed to know that?
That,
it turned in to park their cars.
How was I supposed to know they were gonna park their cars?
Okay.
No, my heart rate.
is too low right now not earning any okay up my heart rate
again oh my god all my money my thousand dollars god i had a
thousand dollars oh shit whoops
Yeah, that's fine.
I don't need that.
I'm not buying food to up my heart rate.
I do it naturally.
My height and heart rate is all natural.
Okay.
That's fine.
I don't need that.
I don't need enhancement food to up my chances.
The old...
I do it the old-fashioned way with pure adrenaline.
It's fine.
I don't buy the 25 ones.
Oh, oh.
Nice.
That's what I like to see.
A good old $2.
Oh.
And $3.
Let's go.
Alright.
Three whole dollars.
It's fine.
I'll just do that.
Okay.
$1.
$25.
Made back all the money I lost.
Okay, made back one of the tickets I bought.
Winner, winner.
Chicken dinner.
Okay.
$1.
Alright, another $25.
Free roll.
I got my free roll, guys.
Winner.
Wonder has to be another one.
Oh, $21.
Oh, $22.
Oh!
That's two whole tickets.
I can buy more of these.
My heart rate's slowly going up.
Okay, one dollar.
Okay, that's fine.
These are big ticket items.
Big ticket items mean big wins.
That's fine.
I'll make it back, guys.
CZZ, C, 20, 20.
21, 22, 40.
I made it back.
Look at that.
Doubters.
Who was a doubter?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Doubters back the fucked off.
Look at that.
Oh, my God.
And my heart rate's going up.
We're all winning today.
Another 20.
21.
It's fine.
More my heart rate is up.
The higher chances we can to win.
God damn, I'm so good at scratching.
It's just...
I was just born with it.
Sometimes it's...
Some people are just born with it.
You can't...
You can't grind for this.
You just gotta have the natural born talent.
Alright.
Nice.
Uh.
Okay.
Practically made back everything we lost.
I'm not very good at math.
I'm just a prodigy.
It's a prodigy of scratching.
Oh!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
Where's my car?
Oh, back to the car.
Where's the car?
All right, back to business.
Wait, where did I get through it?
Oh, not that one.
All right, back to business, guys.
Can I let them distract us?
Oh, my God.
Oh!
Holy shit, that's a lot of money.
I definitely think opening cases.
Shit.
Crisis already!
okay okay oh shit all right all right back to scratching
back to scratching guys okay we're fine we're fine
okay oh just one dollar it was fine that's okay We're just
in a little slump right now.
Just a little slump.
Alright.
Oh?
Oh, it's just $1.
Just small little slumps.
Small little slumps.
And then we're going to go back up.
My gun.
Just doesn't hit the same as high as anymore, guys.
Just doesn't feel the same.
Doesn't feel the same when I first got all these.
I just need the big numbers.
The big numbers.
The big hundos.
shit
Yeah, no no no no no no no that was close that was close oh
Oh my god, that was close.
That was so close.
Oh It's okay, it's okay.
We're still okay.
We're still okay
I feel like the bricked up one the bricked up one is a bit
of a scam oh my god please okay where do i put it okay i'm
just getting 20s i where are the big numbers okay
one dollar another dollar god it's just dollars and 20s
where was that 400 high 25?
It's not the same.
Not the same when I hit that 400.
Not my... You're right, you're right.
It's just not my day.
No, I'm pretty sure they're all empty, guys.
I made sure to spam click that shit.
Maybe.
No, no, don't do it.
You're flying too close to the sun, Doki.
You don't need that chocolate.
You don't need that enhancement bar.
For your lottery tickets.
You can do this all natural.
That's how you won that four hundo.
Remember that.
You don't need to take performance enhancing drugs, Doki.
You can relive your glory days without it.
Alright.
All natural gambling.
We're not going to dope up our heart rate.
no don't worry guys the other one the other one is like due
at the end of the month that one's due at the end of the
month so i'm just gonna scratch a little longer
that one doesn't have a timeline
oh my god not again Okay.
Wait, where did I through it?
Is that it?
Oh, that it is.
Okay.
Okay, another 40.
I'll make it back soon.
I'm making it back slowly.
Okay, $1.
$20.
Age!
Um...
Age Restia!
I'm sorry if I pronounce.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry if I pronounced your name wrong.
Address to you.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Oh, we had a good stream.
Just scratching a lot.
Oh, oh, my God.
That was a good luck raid.
Oh, my God.
That was 500.
You guys know what that means.
Oh, my God, not that.
It's time.
It's time to cross the road.
Okay, let's make sure nobody's.
All right.
It's time.
time to cross the road okay oh my god that was a lucky raid
right there that was a lucky raid oh my god 500 see guys
never quit never quit gambling in game in game though in
game why did the dokey bird cross the road so she can open
her cases all right put this here You see that?
Yeah.
I unboxed that.
You see that right here?
Yeah.
I unboxed that.
It's time to celebrate.
It's time to unbox more cases, guys.
Yeah.
Oh!
$33.
I'm up.
I'm up right now.
Hey, watch me do it again.
Yeah, you see that knife?
Watch me do that again.
holy shit oh my god another purple is oh shit oh shit it's
okay all right i have a hundred i have a hundred to do this
it's fine guys what was the limit again i don't i don't know
i have a backup okay i can do one more i could do one more
before i just try and find a backup wait unless i can do
also do one more i can do one more i can do another one i
can do one more i can do one more i'm not flying too close
this side i remember the limit.
Oh my god.
I could do one more, I think.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh my, okay, okay.
We gotta find beer.
Oh my god.
There must be some beer lying around.
Surely some gamers were alcoholics.
Surely.
Surely we had some alcoholic gamers here.
That's... We're my alcoholic gamers.
Where are they?
What is this?
Oh no, not that.
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
Where's the beer, bro?
This is the one I drank, right?
Oh, nice.
I knew it.
Okay.
All right.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he go?
No.
Oh, no.
It clipped through.
I was trying to place it gently.
Oh, no.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I got another one.
Oh, no.
That was the only one.
Wait.
wait I can't drink this one oh no it's right there I see it
I see it no that was the only cat left oh no surely no no
it's right on there okay it's fine it's fine surely oh my
god oh my god i knew it i knew it okay i'm gonna put this
gently here all right all right there you go we can unbox it
we are still fine we can still go we can still keep going
nice we keep going we can still keep going we can still keep
going there's no countdown
I'm flat.
Okay, I do one sip.
Alright, there you go.
One sip is all I need.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
I've got another one.
I've got another bonus.
Here you go.
Alright, here you go.
Go again.
We need to keep going.
Oh, nice.
We still keep going.
Oh,
you see that, guys?
I told you.
A blue carambit.
Let's fucking go.
Oh, my God.
Guys, unboxing crates might be the easiest thing I've ever
done.
Never, never stop gambling.
In-game.
In-game, guys.
It just works, guys.
all right let's see what's the ATM for I never oh oh is it
for borrowing money are there any other okay all right the
slot machines are a scam though I will say all right let's
cross the road Yoki's gonna cross the road whoa whoa okay
all Go, go, go, go!
Alright.
I saw some.
You know what?
Let's see if we can get the big numbers.
There we go.
I bet you.
I bet you we can hit jackpot.
Look at this.
$100,000.
Today's our day.
Today is our fucking day.
Oh.
It's not finished.
Oh, I saw one more.
Today's that day, guys.
A hundred, a hundred grand.
One.
Twenty.
Twenty-five.
We're getting closer.
We're inching closer.
Oh.
What happened?
Where?
Where did my ticket go?
Where did it go?
Um.
Satan has your ticket now.
Oh, I don't need that weak-ass ticket.
I just won myself $200.
You can have that loser ticket.
The sacrifice.
Oh, shit.
There, see?
easy.
Oh my, I thought that was $100.
I was like, oh my God, the whole $1.
That sacrifice for a big winner.
Winner, winner.
Chicken dinner.
All right.
Oh my God.
I never stop winning.
hard beating me you know it's just it gets so tiresome to
win all the time guys sometimes sometimes it's just so so
tiring to just always keep winning yo you know just never
stops never punish you can't keep getting away with this all
right one dollar 20s oh it's raining 20s right now oh my two
a thousand dollars oh my uh did the world said more 20 for
dokeybird the world said yes losing that one ticket was the
key After sacrificing that one ticket.
That's...
Oh!
Look at that.
It's just all three digits.
All three digits.
So put this here.
Put it here just in case for emergencies.
That's my heart medication.
It's a good old Gatorade.
Alright.
Remember...
I told you.
was a slump when we were only getting 20s.
Never stop.
Oh my god.
There you go.
One's fine.
One sip's fine.
Oh shit.
One sip is... Oh shit.
Okay.
All right.
Maybe we shouldn't.
We were a bit too close to the sun.
Just a little too close.
right there oh my god three grand we're with the big boys
now we're partying up there with the big boys okay we gotta
definitely uh what are these heart rate oh wait these are
new with this here oh my god okay wait actually i should
drink all of it just in case just in case all right one
dollar twenty twenty five come on you said this is top 10
pro 10 top prizes of 100 grand where is my 100 grand come on
you promised me a hundred grand here okay you're 15 15 ones
all right come on come on mama needs a new car she doesn't
drive but she just wants it in her she just wants it in the
garage never to be touched again it's like a little status
symbol oh my god there you go he got me should I drink all
of it.
That was a lot of money.
A whole $1.
Like, car collector moment.
Eh.
Will I ever get...
Is there even...
Does 100 grand even exist?
Do they even exist in this game?
Or is it just bait?
Bait to make you keep scratching at the possibility that you
can get 100 grand.
grand okay oh my god hundred dollars it's just like the
appeal of maybe you could potentially get a hundred grand
but you never get a hundred grand it's not bait if you win
it
no no no no no there you go but you keep scratching
everything is fine We can still keep scratching.
Nothing to worry about, guys.
We can still keep scratching.
Okay, $20.
Another dollar.
Okay.
Come on, I want to know what it's like.
I want to know what it's like to hit...
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I want to know what it's like to hit four digits.
What is it like?
Come on.
Just let me feel it.
Let me feel that rush.
Seeing that hundred grand.
Just want to know.
Oh!
Oh my god.
500.
It's not the same.
It's not the same, guys.
When you hit so many 500s, it just becomes like nothing now.
when you when you build that tolerance it doesn't it doesn't
feel the same like the first time
right the thrill is not the same right i'll scratch all of
that and then be like boom oh my god oh
Just hearing the Okay, watch this Watch this
The little Ding, ding, ding In my brain The serotonin rush
Are you kidding me?
Okay, I'm guys gonna say nothing hit.
The new lottery meta drop.
You just scratch all the numbers and then you feel all of it
hit at the same time.
Guys.
The dopamine.
Watch.
Oh.
Let's feel it all hit.
All at once.
You don't know which one's the winner.
And then you do.
Oh my god.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Okay.
Please, Doki, this is an intervention.
Guys, guys, I swear I can stop.
Guys, I can stop anytime I want, guys.
At any time I want.
I swear, guys.
Okay.
I can stop at any time I want.
Anytime.
Eh.
Right.
No, no, no, no, no.
I do want to stop, guys.
I do.
I- Oh!
Where's it?
Where is it?
That card had 150!
There you go.
I can stop at any time I want, guys.
Anytime.
I swear.
It's just- I just- just one more.
Just one more.
Just one more hit.
Oh my god.
Just one more.
Guys, just one more.
A winner.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
That was a lot.
Just one more.
99% of gamblers quit before they hit it big.
In game.
Guys.
Oh yeah.
go there you go okay come on come on give me that that 100
grand come on come on you know i know you are here i know
that 100 grand exists guys i know the dream is real oh my
god 400 000 i might as well hit 100 grand by then oh my god
that's 100.
watch this
I saw it.
I saw it at 100.
Oh.
You see 150?
Right.
You know what?
I have an idea.
What if we...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
I have an idea.
Oh my god.
This is a new meta.
Yeah.
$20.
Okay, this is the new meta, guys.
Put all of these here.
We're at 233.
Where's the other one?
Wait, where did the other one go?
I'm preloading.
Okay.
20.
2015.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
Okay, I think I knew where...
I'm going to put you here.
And then I'll put you here.
You're the 150 big one.
ones.
I don't know what happened to the other one, but you're...
Okay.
Oh shit.
25, 15.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
I know there's another big one here.
I know there's another big one.
It's just waiting for me to scratch it.
Come on.
15, 20.
It's just waiting.
waiting for for home waiting for daddy right here daddy's
here come on come on it's right here
come on i'm at 230 i'm literally at the cusp of a heart
attack i'm right there i'm at the cusp of a heart attack 235
beats per minute for the last 30 minutes
i'm like taunting death right now he's at my door waiting to
knock at it he's tapping the watch being like hurry up tap
tap okay all right oh 200 dollars all right 200 all right
that's the 200
Oh my god, just thinking about all the amount I'm cashing
out right now
Okay Oh my god, another 500 Oh my god, another 500 just
casually sitting there Right here
There's no way 500 is like There's no way 500 is the most I
can get Surely you can get 100,000 grand.
Come on.
I haven't seen that yet.
I need to know.
I need to know if it's possible.
If those numbers exist.
That's all I want to know.
I just want to know.
If I can get any higher.
I just need to know.
Can I possibly get any higher?
just all i see the most i've ever seen was 25.
i don't think it exists guys i've done it all i've unboxed
two knives i've unboxed two knives lost a thousand dollars
at the casino and all i saw was five hundred dollars i just
i need to know i need to know if it's real dream or not.
Yeah.
Come on.
There's one more here.
All right, I think it's time.
I wonder.
Okay.
I'm going to test it out.
I'm going to test my theory out.
I'm going to put this here.
All right, I'm ready.
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, I fucked up.
I fucked it up.
Because I...
No, no, no, no.
That's too close.
No, no.
Okay.
Okay, okay, that was a little too risky.
That was a little too risky, but I can do it again.
Okay.
I can do this again.
I can try this again.
I can try my theory up.
Okay, this is my theory.
What is this?
All I have to do, I do this.
I do this.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Wait, wait, I gotta try this again.
Alright, this is my theory, guys.
I do this.
And then...
No!
Okay.
Okay, which one was it?
Which one was it?
Which one did I throw?
I want to know.
Which one was it?
Yeah.
Okay.
It's okay.
I need to know which one was it.
Which one was the one I threw?
Was it this?
Which one was it?
I want to test my theory!
I need to know!
yeah
okay I have a plan you got put this here I buy this put this
here I buy this all right here we go
okay all right did it work I fucking knew that theory was
wrong look at that practically nothing look at that nothing
I was two seconds from a heart attack and it gave me jack
shit I knew it I knew it didn't matter guys I knew it it
didn't matter how close you were to getting a stroke
walking that didn't lie I knew it I knew it didn't matter
all right how about this see look at I bought this ticket at
235 didn't matter look at that look at that try again look
at that $20 15 look at that all right look at that okay I
bought it I bought it when I was close to heart attack look
at that just silly 20s and 25s i knew it i knew it didn't
matter i knew it cashing it all in
i knew it yeah wait but what if i can go higher you think
that's possible You think like I just keep scratching and
scratching and scratching?
Oh my god, wait I have an idea.
I have an idea.
I'll test my new theory out.
I'm gonna test my new theory.
Watch this.
Okay.
All right.
I need to fly closer this than you're so right.
You're so right.
I just need to fly closer.
And they fly even closer.
So close to the sun.
that there could only be winners.
Here.
It's gonna go like this.
Wait.
I think.
I think you're right.
Guys!
We're figuring it out.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's the plan.
Okay.
All right.
All we have to do is we scratch this.
Scratch this.
yes you see that and then oh my god okay let's we gotta buy
this put this here and then scratch this
okay okay okay that's as close as i could get that that was
as close as i where did i throw it where did i i didn't even
get to see i didn't get the sea.
Where did it I didn't even get the sea.
I didn't get the sea.
I didn't I don't even know.
I didn't even get to see how far we went.
It's probably in the pile.
It probably is.
How is there more?
Oh, oh, that was the $100 rune.
okay all right okay we'll do this oh my god let's test out
the one dollar one maybe okay okay it's just one dollar it's
just one dollar okay but like how much is the ten dollar how
much can you win I'm the $10, though.
Other than $25.
I would assume this is the biggest you can get.
Okay.
We'll cash in the scratched ones.
And then buy the normal ones.
Okay.
I see you.
Alright.
No!
We're just...
Oh my god, there it is.
Okay.
Moment of truth.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh, my theory.
My theory is working.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Okay.
38.
All right.
The theory works, guys.
The theory works.
All right.
I'm ready.
We wait.
We've...
I'm sorry.
I'm doing closer to the sun.
Went out doing what she loved.
Scratchy, scratchy.
Now I must confess.
We're not even a confessional in this church.
That upon her throne of trash, she falls.
No.
I am not forgiven Oh my I bought by the way I bought From
the same company Who did the confessional I bought Several
new gadgets But I need to find it I forgot to show you guys
it But I need to find it I'll show it to you guys By the way
Tomorrow is no stream Because like Tomorrow is my actual
rest day now dude thank you for the tier one so thank you
thank you it's they're they're a little silly they're also a
little silly ones just just they're just like the
confessionals um i'll i'll spoil you guys on what one of
them is one of them is a sad trombone a sad trombone it
literally is a like a miniature trombone and when you press
it it goes I think I in my I needed the one time I needed it
the most the moment she needs it it's not there it literally
goes I press it all right all right it's time it's time for
the other sponsor I wish it did they don't do the world's
smallest violin unfortunately but i do have the world's
smallest trombone yeah the trombone would have been super
handy here all right it's time all right let me look up look
up what i need to do for the next one sorry it was supposed
to be like a quick game but it was definitely i might have
got a little too little too into it i just wanted to know
what it'd be like to hit a hundred grand guys that's all i
wanted to know if it was real guys i just wanted to know was
it real or not just a little just a little bit i wasn't it's
not like i wasn't addicted or anything i just i just wanted
to know if the hundred grand was real or just a myth i'm
just a psa to tell you gambling is dangerous like oh shit
oops back accidentally playing on weekend queue forgot about
that oops all right marble rivals here we go at oops oh no i
forgot about the weekend cues oh no also i just realized
that my aim but i was like flashing in and up because i
forgot to i forgot to fix that give me a sec there you go
there you go
Boop boop It's fixing everything Alright Done Okay Maybe I
can slowly get into the degenerate cues I hate the weekend
cues Oh my god My first mistake Getting into the
Oh I didn't even realize the game was super quiet You were
just listening to me like scratching tickets by my you guys
sitting here in the countdown you're just listening to me
scratching tickets to no sound my audity was like by the way
the game is really quiet but I didn't see their I didn't see
their message because I might have got a little too I got a
little too I might have overdone it a little bit there
alright let's see
I haven't played rivals in a long time The last time was
during my sponsor Was for the sponsor Like the early access
one So it has been a while since I've touched rivals So
can't wait to get flamed by people The only reason why is
that I Not a fan of triple support And I've been I'm just
not a fan of the new meta at the moment so that's why i
haven't played rivals in a while um i just feel like triple
support is so boring and uh gambit is just not fun to to
play against like at first it was because that you know it
was new and shiny but now like when everyone else has sort
of mastered gambit gambit gambit and gambit loki it's just
it's just very frustrating to play with and against so
that's why I haven't touched rivals in a while or rivals
rank in general I just play every support I play every
support except for Jeff because I don't know how to do to
hurt his alts I'm very bad at his alts so I don't really
play him a lot but I just find triple support so fucking
boring to play it's just not fun and it's very frustrating
because whichever team runs triple support and then you get
like egotistical DPS that doesn't want to swap to triple
support even though they know we're losing because the enemy
team's running triple support and they just refuse to run
the third support while the other DPS was willing to swap to
the triple support because they're like oh we're losing let
me swap to triple support like the other DPS and then my DPS
will be like no I'm just gonna keep playing DPS like I don't
care like and that's very frustrating general because of it
all right yeah see like new season i haven't even touched
new season yet i haven't i haven't touched the new season
yet so yeah give me a sec let me yeah let me just keep
hitting myself in the brick wall and see if anything changes
all right give me a sec let me check
I'm just checking on.
Because I know I changed it for stuff.
So I want to make sure.
Bum.
All right.
Yeah.
Everything looks good.
All right.
Let me.
Oh, yeah.
I did play on my alt account.
I think like was it yesterday or two?
two days ago and it's so funny because i wanted to play dps
so obviously i played on an alt account because i wasn't
gonna play dp i wasn't gonna throw games and um on my main
and then it was really funny i meant like playing rank as in
like my my like main like just um like actually trying on my
main but i did i wanted to play dps because i just want to
shoot things and then so i played like two games like
yesterday or day before just to see and it was so funny
Because I want to try out Elsa.
I really want to try out Elsa.
Because the only time I did Elsa was during early access.
And it's really funny.
Because I was carrying.
And then someone in my chat.
Some of my team was like.
Because I had 30 plus kills.
And then this other DPS had like 8.
No she is fun.
She is fun when you get your combos right.
So the other DPS had 8.
And I had 30.
And then.
um our support was that uh bro you're so shameless boosting
this wolverine and i was like question mark like it's like
obviously i was like i don't know who this other guy is and
then and then he was like what's your what uh what's your
main and i was like oh i play support on my main and yeah
but what's your what's your name and i was like just google
me because my account was And he's like, okay, but what is
the name I have to Google?
I'm like, think about it.
Because I was on not Doki Bird.
And so he's like, what's the name of the account?
And I'm like, bro, just think about it.
The disguise, it just works.
And you're like, there's no way she could absolutely,
there's no way she's actually Doki.
bird and says not dokey bird like not dokey bird it could be
anybody um so so they're like they're so like what do i
google like what's your account name who do i look up i'm
like bro just think about it just think like where what else
would you what do i google yes i thought it was really
fucking funny it's just like but what's your account name
um anyway all right let me pull this up real quick before i
begin i pull up the sponsorship thing Oops.
Oops, I closed the wrong tab, though.
All right.
Let's see.
Enabled.
Wait, did I?
Okay, I am all Marvel rivals.
I was like, am I on it?
Okay.
All right.
This stream is spot...
Oh, wait.
I forgot to start it.
I start the streamer read.
All right, there you go.
This stream is sponsored by Marvel Rivals.
Marvel Rivals Season 6.5 is here.
Elsa Bloodstone joins Marvel Rivals and is free to play.
The game keeps leveling up with non-stop updates, new
heroes, new teamers, and new costumes.
Don't miss all the new content, just dropping.
So yeah, basically you can try Elsa Bloodstone right now.
Anyway, let's play Rivals and play weekend queues and see
how bad it is.
DM2 while we're at it.
Also, I guess just derank as well.
I didn't even realize Alcatraz I was deranking.
Might as well.
Alright.
Whoa, here we go.
Yeah, just screw it.
We full send.
Oh yeah, I wanted to see the new Times Square.
You can get a chance to see the new Times Square.
The new updates they added.
Yeah, Elo terrorism starts now uh i'm gonna fly let's fly
around yeah happy new year sun oh yeah and then the e-daters
the e-daters can go here so if they added this new feature
where you can sit here and
so if you're for valentine's day so where you and you're on
your e-day and you can you know or be a loner like me
sitting by myself
just you know or you're to be like me just sitting alone I
don't know.
this is mildly depressing anyway anyway that's an option oh
and then there's the line dances too yeah we're here for you
man so yeah it's great it's it's it's great guys we're all
the we're all the other where's the e-daters we're all the
guys oh yeah i could do oh that's cool oh i like that oh
that's cool i could join in on the lawn dance that's right
all right i need a i need a fine i need a no i was gonna
re-queue time square i gotta find i gotta find the e-daters
i wanna know
I want to know, do they exist?
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright, oh fuck.
I don't know, honestly.
What even, I guess Cloak is meta now, right?
I'm going to Cloak.
I heard Cloak is, like, hard meta now.
Because of...
Yeah, please ban Gambit.
I do not feel like playing Gambit.
yeah is adam meta i think off triple support he is maybe a
triple adam just doesn't do enough heals he doesn't do
enough heals to adjust it by being um um being a dual
support you can fly yes but like that's flying doesn't heal
flying flying doesn't give heals guys unfortunately
Flying is cool and everything.
Yeah, who needs heals when you can fly?
So, it heals us.
That's true.
He can finally move.
I'm so proud of him.
Take your hero or villain.
I'm not judging.
He finally has movement.
Yeah, as the most, the most surprising thing is that he
finally has the most movement ability out of all.
All the supports now.
Of all of them, he is the most, like, anti-dive.
He has the most escapability of movement.
After being in a wheelchair for 80 years, it's a Christmas
miracle.
Yeah, but it's very low-accurate.
It's flying.
Like, it's literally pulled from the movies.
seconds before you attack get ready all right it has been a
while so i can't i'm going to get ready i'm bracing myself
to get yelled at it's sunday i haven't played it a while and
i'm ready to get yelled at i've been playing so many
different games the last two weeks
all you need to do is capture the mission area got it all
right i don't that's still your speed boost right i shall
become why i've been the yellow terrorist for a while why
strange if you have the option to why not play i'm so
confused yeah why not mag if you have the chance to why not
play mag okay I know I can hear like I can hear dives so I'm
clicking I'm saving this for myself never mind I guess not I
guess I'm not saving this for myself yeah no he's dead if
only he was playing mag tribal first ever only hope never
mind why did he swap off mag you know what you get a moon
for the the copies how do you decide to die right there bro
what's going on he's like i love first i'm like oh i think i
might die to mag not gonna lie oh there we go there you go
first miss sake we did not play mag first point oh my god is
he still gonna hold first or not you know what all right
here we go when i won when i won oh my god i should have
been that was my bad i threw that i should have been on
cloak but i don't love no if i was on cloak i could have
floated away i could have floated away that's fine we still
won that look at that the one in our back line he's out yeah
that's fine he took too long to kill me so my ult still
lived and the mag did have all we take those oh no on the
right yeah We take those.
He took too long.
Hey, Mag.
Is that crazy?
I hear like footsteps right on us.
Okay, I expected you.
I can not blink on.
Okay.
All right.
Look at her.
Look, look, look, look.
All right.
Oh.
Oh, goodbye.
Unless...
That's fine, I'm here.
It's fine, I'm here.
Did they got rid of the...
I mean, I thought I only do it because they used to have a
movement speed.
A speed boost when you fade, but I don't know what they got.
It feels so slow.
Totally shit.
We're down one walkie.
We're down two.
All right.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Let's hope that we can kill people here.
Yay!
We got the point.
All right.
I mean, we can push with this, though, technically.
Oh, no.
Nah.
Oh, I won't push with this.
I can only push.
I want to push this so bad.
But also, I don't know if you ask Maga.
okay 10 seconds okay 10 seconds i'm gonna wait i think
that's 10 already right all right i'm doing this day oh that
killed a lot though
oh wait nice all right one all right that's fine that's five
oh my god i'm okay i'm okay i am oh no oh i'm in i'm in i'm
in it i'm in it there we go oh my god we're fine we're so
healthy we're so healthy we're so thank you for the 250s
thank you thank you back thank you for the rain thank you
thank you i've had a good stream thank you everybody i'm
just playing some rivals today on the weekend queues the
worst time to play rake it's been a while since i've played
it's been a while surprisingly i know me taking a while play
rivals but i'm not a fan of this meta at the moment that's
why i'm taking i took a little break from rivals what do you
think or oral do we yeah mag protected me but like it
definitely It's okay.
It's okay.
It's still It's okay.
I believe I believe in us Oh, we can oh, that's so cool I
didn't know I could join in like I thought it was only a
time square thing Am I actually do we have do we take away
our movement boost Doesn't feel like it's faster anymore It
used to be a lot faster so I'm like confused Okay I feel
like it's...
She's like, um, it's still there?
It does not feel that fast.
Oh my god, man.
Holy shit, that's a lot of damage.
That's a lot.
Oh my god, that is a lot of damage.
Yeah.
Oh, I cannot heal that.
I feel like they like nerfed the speed a little.
Because it does not feel as fast as it was in the past.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
All right, I could up this, but like...
All right, here we go.
Let's hope you have shield.
All right, that's fine.
Oh, wait, we two teammates die.
That's fine.
He didn't get me, so it's fine, I guess.
Oh, my God.
Holy fuck.
I am so dead.
So, you guys are explaining me while we're dying, poking
back at you?
I didn't even got a token Elsa to win.
not my fault not my fault surprisingly not my fault but i
already have my ult again what the fuck to be fair we have a
storm which ideally is not great i could literally alt again
here okay i'm gonna actually have a real focal yeah let's go
again guys
What the fuck?
How did they die to El-Salt again?
They died to El-Salt again.
Storm got buffed.
Storm is still ass.
Doesn't matter if she got buffed.
She's still ass.
They have an El-Salt.
up doesn't matter if storm got buff and Elsa delete storm
without tie I wouldn't know the real power of the light
force but good round Jeff though we have an actual RP here
are you okay this guy we actually have an RP here yeah who
said that who said that
the fact that i sort of have even though they could their
assists it doesn't look good when we have three dps and
three two three of our dps are getting out damaged by the
all of the enemy team yeah i prefer teams of four but i can
make this work that's a little embarrassing guys just a
little bit that's just a little embarrassing here still one
you're probably nice oh nice we got rid of that too yeah we
should push up ideally we would push up yeah ideally oh yeah
try and do some little pokes
oh my god oh my god save him save him he's a hero save him
oh my god i bro he got pulled 20 times
Fuck!
I am a little...
Guys!
Guys, okay, I was gonna sit.
Oh my god, I...
Okay, okay, okay.
That's unlucky.
Wait, this is winnable?
This is winnable!
This is so winnable!
lift oh my god it was so winnable our mag our mag did it the
rest of our team did it it truly was winnable and he used
and he used mag up and he used mag up and jeff up on my
counters
on top
holy Holy fuck.
Holy fuck.
Release what?
Okay.
Where is Iron Mag?
I hope he's okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Yay!
of you we did it oh never mind we did not yet not yet yeah
we did it it was truly winnable upgrade thank you for the
bitties thank you thank you just getting rid of the rest of
my bitties thank you again for the bitties yeah you you guys
suck jeff the lad shark
Okay, buddy.
Holy slob.
All right.
Yeah, holy larper.
Bro.
Jeff would never say that.
Not my Jeff.
Jeff would never insult me.
I refuse to believe it.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Can I get RDE daters?
Oh, it's the little swing.
swimming pool!
Oh!
Oh my god!
It's the little gym swimming pool!
Wait, wait.
There's an e-data here.
Hello!
Hey!
Wait.
No!
Okay, I mean, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm not jealous.
Wait, how do I...
i forgot how to emote guys how do i emote again it's been so
long it's been so long what's the button what's the button
oh there it is wait What's the point?
I guess.
Why
did he get close to me?
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
I guess we don't need personal space, guys.
I was like, whoa, he got closer.
Whoa.
All right, here we go again.
Actually, we can go right.
Actually, no, cloak and dagger is just too strong.
It's just too strong.
I think Infants is, like, not good anymore.
You have to play cloak and dagger.
Like, her all is just way too good to not play it
he was very yeah i was like whoa whoa
all right here we go i swear to god why is none of you guys
bad and gambit i swear to god if i i swear to fucking god if
i oh thank god okay i didn't say if we are not second bad at
gambit that's what a risk we're taking there
Crisis averted No if I had moments where my team would Not
ban Gambit And then ask Like the DPS and tanks won't ban
Gambit And then ask the supports to play the Gambit Even
though the supports would be locking something else
And then blame the supports being like Oh Why are you guys
so bad at Gambit Or like why aren't you guys playing Gambit
like the other team And then I'm just like, then why?
Like, why are you putting it on us?
You guys were the ones that wanted us to play Gambit.
They're like, we need a fan of this and this.
And Gambit's not even included in the rotation.
And that grinds my gears.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
Yeah, if they don't instantiate, a lot of gambit on your
team, then like, just ban gambit.
It's so annoying.
Like, I used to like playing gambit, but now I'm over it.
It's not...
Just not as fun anymore.
It's just not as fun, you know?
It's already lost its appeal.
I have to stand near.
holy fuck our angela our angela pulled the entire hook into
the support holy fuck thinking that we knew what to do with
it that's actually crazy like you don't pull him into the
support
why would you pull the hook into the two supports what do
you want us to do That's crazy.
Oh yeah, apparently meta tanks is...
Was it rude thing now?
I'm one of my friends.
Like, here's Hulk.
And then we couldn't heal, like, the rest of our teams
because of it.
Like...
Because we're too busy trying to get the Hulk off our back.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna lose this Holy fuck I might be dead actually.
Oh, we're fine.
We're fine.
No, it's okay
I hope I hope I hope the I hope the I hope the I hope the I
hope the I
hope okay, well, it's fine my team won my team won The fight
I was like I hope I hope they they're doing it.
I really do
okay it's okay it's okay my team won the fight it's okay my
team won the fight my team won the fight guys it's okay it's
okay the team won i hear the spider man the scooter man
right now the hulk has also like a little scared too cheesy
yeah i'm saving this for the spider-man it's not worth it
it's just not worth it dude okay never mind
oh my god
holy fuck all right let's let's hope he goes oh he doesn't
fly okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
it's okay i was in my head i really did
oh my god that's good that's good i don't have to use this
oh okay i don't think we needed that but that's okay
i am willing to die i will not uh
I am willing to die with my will.
I will not solo off the Spider-Man.
I will
not solo off the Spider-Man.
I mean, okay, that's fine.
Holy fuck, let's hope that we're...
It's okay?
it's no longer okay that's a lot of us that that was a lot
of us
that was way too many oh that is not good
oh they blocked us that's unlucky I might be dead.
Oh, no.
I'm okay.
Alright, it's alright.
It's okay.
We are doing our best.
Healing this.
Oh my god.
Not again.
Oh.
Why does he always bring me?
Like.
He brings the Hulk to supports, but not our DPS.
If he brings him to our DPS, it's fine.
But he brings him directly into the support faces.
And that's when you can tell he's good at grabs, but only he
only grabs like...
He doesn't grab the right people.
Or takes them to the right places.
He just needs to take them to the right people.
Like literally, that's all.
Okay, I'm just hoping.
Please help.
Okay, that's good.
But then she's so dead.
She's alive.
We are no longer...
Oh my god.
We are alive somehow.
Somehow.
We...
Free all possible.
Holy fuck.
Oh, I'm trying.
Okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
okay I have all suit I don't have to use it not yet not yet
okay cool me first oh portal time portal Turtle tap.
Alright, let's...
Alright, here we go.
Oh, that was a little too late.
Unlucky.
I'm trying to keep you guys up.
I really am.
This is where we die.
This is possibly where we die.
This is...
Oh.
They just had more ults.
And I am just gonna die with that ult.
Oh.
Why did we back up there?
That was...
very unlucky.
It's a Celestial 3 lobby, I believe.
Yeah, Invis really likes to hold alts for some reason.
I don't understand why.
If he alted the moment my alt was down, I think it would
have been fine because our Punisher would have lived.
But our Invis really likes to hold his alt until until like
he's dead dead like he's like I think we're gonna die like
he just needs to be one the two seconds faster with his ult
like literally he waits until someone gets picked and then
ults which is not ideal it's not ideal at all because our
Punisher did not have to die there if we had ulted there um
Because we had alters there, the moment my alt was down, our
Punisher would have lived.
Yeah.
Like, he did it way too many times.
Not just to me, but to our teammates.
Which is like, that's like the mistake that he's been doing.
Two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
They didn't even do that.
It would be fine, I feel.
Why did he stop covering for us?
I was like, I was like, don't worry, I'll shield you all.
And then he left us so fast.
I was not ready for him to leave us already.
Yo, man.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Just can't get this.
Don't worry, we're all stacked up here.
We're all stacked up now.
Holy fuck!
Punisher!
You are!
Punisher, you're crazy!
Oh my...
I can't... I guess...
Oh my god, I almost died from that.
There we go.
I almost ran through this strange board.
I'm scared.
My Punisher is such Like, like, he just stood still.
He didn't even try and move.
I was just like, what are you doing?
Why are you just letting him shoot you for free?
We can use Invis here.
Alright, that's fine.
Our Punisher was not in the Invis all.
It's okay.
We don't need a B in it.
Oh, oh, do we lose all support?
Yeah.
Okay, maybe our Punisher is a little stupid too.
Maybe why would you walk backwards?
Holy fuck.
Okay, it's a Punisher and it envisage you.
The fact that our Punisher walked backwards is insane.
I did not expect that.
What a play, honestly.
Truly the play of the century.
And then our Invis is frontlining.
What is...
Okay, all right
All right, I'm not all taking this there's no reason to like
there is no reason to hope that like
Holy fuck Why was yeah, I was just like why is my invasive
frontlining into a tank right now That is very questionable.
I've seen a lot of very questionable plays.
Definitely this one was one of them.
Oh, that is really bad for me.
I'm just hoping that he did not.
Yeah, no, we were not living that.
They used everything, though.
They used...
There you go.
They used a lot.
It's fine They literally used They used yeah, it's kind of
worth it.
I don't know why my It was kind of worth it though
Holy shit Well, what why is there a Punisher behind me like?
I'm autistic.
I can't read.
Can't see either.
You can't see either.
It was a Punisher on the point.
How did he get in there?
You don't have to read.
You have to have eyes.
You don't even need a read to be like, why the fuck is he
there?
there I
look we were all healing him you cannot blame us we actually
were all healing the the Punisher everyone like me and the
Invis were healing the Punisher like there was nothing we
could do there the healers tried.
It's so hard.
Alright.
Here we go.
Average.
Thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Alright.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
You know what's crazy?
He didn't go Angela and fucking pull teammates into the
supports.
And I think that's why it went a lot easier.
We literally lost the first one because he pulled the Hulk
into two supports.
Blocking the supports from...
He pulled a dive tank into the supports.
Blocking the supports from healing.
The one thing that can block a support is a dive character.
And he pulled a dive into us.
Which was insane.
I was just like, how do you do that?
Thank you.
Like a thing would be easier to deal with than a Hulk.
Jesus.
A lot of damage.
I don't know about that anymore.
They have Rocket Raccoon!
They have rock!
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
Don't worry, guys.
Push up.
Surely someone's not gonna get res'd or anything.
What do you mean?
Why would you TP there?
Just TP on point!
Oh my...
Sorry, there's a bad portal.
Oh my god.
Why did they...
Why did you TP there?
That was season one meta!
Season one, yes!
Everyone just TP's on point.
Everyone TP's on point.
Yeah, we have to use...
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
I'm dead.
I'm actually dead.
I'm dead from that.
Oh, my God.
Why did our punish you all sit?
Wait, our punish you all sit.
No, bro.
I don't know what that one was.
Why did our punish you all sit?
Oh, my God.
Oh my god.
He ulted!
He actually ulted!
Guys, I don't think this is winnable now.
My team...
My team is so special.
I had to do... I had to ult that because it's like more so
to bait the ult off if I don't...
Why?
Okay, that is something.
But like...
I'm trying my best to heal all of you guys.
I really am.
I was literally the only one that didn't get hit.
I swear to God if I get...
Please, please, please, she'll be...
Please!
She'll...
Oh my gosh!
Why don't we have a mag?
I can't play cloak.
I cannot play cloak into this.
Oh my god.
Please fuck.
The fact that we have no mag.
Oh my god.
The current score is 3.
No, my entire team's a mess.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
If it's not mag, it's Iron Man.
I knew they had Iron Man too.
That's the thing.
The portal.
The shitty ass portal where he portaled?
High ground?
Yeah, that was so worth it.
Didn't even portaled correctly.
Didn't even portaled on point.
Gave us a 20 minute walking distance to the point.
I forgot what we can use, man.
I'm fucking playing Loki.
This ain't winnable.
I just want to play Loki at this point.
I thought he would swap off street.
I should have just played Loki there.
On second point.
Might as well.
Yeah.
I could have swapped out cloak too, but I legitimately
thought my team had my back.
I legitimately thought, I was like, don't worry, my team
should have my back.
But my team did not have my back, guys.
It didn't help that I punished your altar when 20 people
died.
It really did not help.
Oh my god.
Guys, I really need you guys to not...
Holy shit.
I really need you guys to not feed.
To not feed, please.
It's not that hard.
To not... Surprisingly, it's not that hard.
We just don't peek.
This is real firepower!
Whoa!
Oh my god, I actually...
Oh my god, I don't...
I literally don't have like fucking anything to...
We just regroup here.
Alright, here we go.
Let's try this.
Oh my god, is that mag?
Is that a fucking mag?
Pull him in And then we go here So we don't know okay And
then I don't know who died there But unfortunate
The supports are safe though at least
Well I don't know Who's safe in there But wait are we
running Triple tank?
Okay.
Unfortunately, I do not have...
Okay, that's unlucky.
That's unlucky.
I did not have shift, so I was like, ooh, that's
unfortunate.
Second chance is over.
All right, let's do this.
I do not really believe in us very much, but...
Guys, can we, like, shoot one person?
Let's all shoot at the Emma.
That would be pretty neat.
That...
That would be pretty neat, guys.
We all shoot at...
We have no damage.
That's also the reason.
Oh.
okay we have to guys we have to get the point
we have to at least be on the point we have to at least be
on the point when we do this guys we they were gonna pull us
away from the cart and i was like guys guys we have to be
touching the cart
we have to be touching cart guys we
This is very annoying though.
I'm trying to...
Oh my god, I have to do this, but I'm actually...
Like, there is a fucking Iron Man behind us!
Holy shit.
There is an Iron Man here and I do not like it.
Oh my god.
I literally cannot.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
No in-vraw now, which is a little scary.
They're down the...
Oh my god, I'm dead.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, no!
Okay, I panicked the fucking thing there.
oh please I really need all charge though oh my god I do not
want to be here but I'm gone I really need all charge I
really need like okay I got it there's my this okay okay
I had to use I wanted to use that see we can oh that's bad I
thought we could do something with that I thought we could
do something to that I thought we get a grab-a-pill get in
here get in here holy fuck thank you no okay I'm in it
Please no, please I'm the only one shooting the Iron Man
Please why is no one shooting him?
Why I can't play anywhere How do we not have anyone turning
around?
Well, you can't expect to do them all Holy shit.
That's crazy.
That's 80k.
80k.
80k healing.
Alright.
Alright, that's fine.
Not me.
My team just can't look behind.
My team.
Almost 80k.
I need to get water, I'll be right back
Just dancing the pain away Oh my god, I forgot how much I
hate weakened cues And I forgot how much I hate this Elo
When I'm like In the lower Elo's When I don't grind Because
it's like You know like things that you think is like common
knowledge And they don't do it Like you know Like that shit
I'm like, what are you doing?
This is so common knowledge.
Why don't you do that?
But it's not for them.
It's not.
So it's like, it like, I'm just like, I don't understand.
I thought, I thought everyone knows this.
You TP to the point.
Not, not the fucking high ground.
That was season one.
High ground was season one.
So it's like, and then our Punisher, Old thing when poor
people were dead, he's like, don't worry, I shall 1v4.
I shall 1v6 and be a hero.
Dude, now I will be the change that I wanna be.
You know, that Punisher was so special.
Speaking of that, I should avoid that Punisher.
I'm gonna avoid that Punisher, actually.
I actually didn't avoid that guy.
I do not want this guy on my team.
He was so brave.
Oh my god.
He wanted to be a hero.
He was not.
Unfortunately.
He was not the hero.
That we've all.
That he wanted it to be.
I'm so sad that you can't emote on the kid.
like what's the point hello hello sir don't worry alone on
don't worry i'm so sad don't worry wolverine i'll be there
for you um bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
bum
not worry.
You might be alone.
On Valentine's Day, the venom will never leave a homie
behind.
Even Wolverine deserves love.
Even you, Wolverine.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
God, why is everyone playing Invis?
I feel like Invis is not that good anymore.
You want me to play Rocket?
Fuck this.
It's Rocket time.
I'm tired.
I'm trying.
I think my favorite...
Wait, what's this?
Nah, that skin sucks.
Alright.
Tata Square has always been a permanent thing.
Jedi, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
I personally don't think Invis is, like, that particularly
strong.
I feel like Loki and Cloak is stronger.
Just get two Cloak Lodes.
I think that's why...
Oh, yeah.
That's why a lot of people are also, like, super tired of
playing right now.
Some of my friends were telling me...
Some of my friends were telling me that, like, they're tired
of...
rank because they're tired of playing against Loki and Cloak
all the time.
It's just not as fun.
Oh my, okay, we bad gamut, thank God.
I feel like Cloak, Loki is just such a better combo.
So I'm surprised like, I guess it's because of this rank, I
guess, because they don't really know.
Oh, alright, here we go.
Oh.
sometimes we take stuff up yeah let's go
let's go hey at least it ain't caked into your firm i don't
feel like playing cloak right now or loki so is rock guitar
yeah Alright, let's go.
Let's do our thing.
Let's go.
I think what can definitely improve Rivals at the moment is
just the nerf supports.
I saw people were talking about it.
Oh, wait, I should.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even see this gap.
Whoops.
I don't know.
For some reason, I was like, oh, is that my Star Lord?
I was like, wait, we don't have a Star Lord.
I was like, don't worry.
My Star Lord is gonna...
My Star Lord is gonna help.
Realizing what...
I was like, wait a minute.
I don't have a Star Lord.
Don't want to have rest.
Did he try to...
Oh.
We don't have a Phoenix, though.
All right, here we go.
And we got picks!
Yay!
Let's go!
Doing my job!
By existing.
I think a great way to improve it is just to make it so that
the heal, like healing doesn't do as much, I think.
And that's a great way.
because like so that people get punished more and also
remove abilities that give shields there's too many of that
i saw a clip of like it was a thor oh my god please come
here there you go stupid oh shit oh shit i'm stupid i'm
stupid oh my god before i die before i die die.
It's okay.
Oh, you got it.
You live.
It's okay.
I still live.
Okay, so we don't have an alt for star lord alt so our
mission right now survive which i think we can definitely do
that right we could definitely do that
it's doable it's doable it is doable Hey, guys.
Fucking idiot.
Yeah, I've never seen a rodent shoot back, did you?
That's right.
I can shoot back.
There we go.
To be fair, most Rockets cat aim I feel like if if healing
was like more like healing makes it so that it's more I
guess like punishable so you don't get like get a jail free
card just because the support is healing you I think that
couldn't improve the you that's why triple support is so
strong healing is just so overpowered now over tuned in
general you should know by now that I'm far from helpless
It's just way too over-tuned.
The forbidden moves.
Rocket fighting back.
A raccoon fighting back.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Once we get this timeline thing sorted out, I'm taking a
long vacation somewhere with lots of stuff to steal.
support it's gonna be interesting honestly a melee support
i'm like curious on how that's gonna work in general hello
hello
whoa hello hello okay it's fine it's fine i i didn't want to
live anyway i'm okay living for losers it's alright oh nice
we won in game in game living's pretty cool guys living is
very cool just just end game oh is that magic gonna be okay
oh look at him crawling there we can just kill him oh shit
i'm sorry all right as long as he doesn't all right guys
it's okay we don't have an ult we don't have an ult for
starlight all but it'll be okay
oh my god he's gonna come for one of us and it's not gonna
be me it's not gonna be it's okay we're back in the cycle we
don't have an all for star lord alt but it will be oh we do
we might actually do i'm gonna let him heal i'm gonna let
her heal i'm gonna let her i'm gonna do the gamer move and
let her heal but then i think i have to start healing down
okay it's okay it's okay it's okay the gamer move the gamer
move i told you i told you it's just i told you
the gamer move that's much better all right i have no idea
who
oh please respawn please oh please come back before he comes
for me
okay there you go there we go here we go oh oh your power no
powers i don't think the powers came back to her i don't
think so We shit.
It's okay.
I think they're TPing?
Oh, nice.
They fucked up the TP.
Oh.
Look at that.
We did it, guys.
See?
Not too bad.
Not too shabby.
We take those.
We fucking take those.
It's that easy, guys.
need we don't need to play meta we'll play with the fuck we
want in this elo
so easy this was yeah i felt like celestial i'm like like
because like high elo is eternity now and celestial three is
like not not very high but the gap between celestial three
and Celestia 1 is very high, like, the skill level.
Oh, hey.
Oh.
It's alright.
I don't need her.
I have Luna Snow.
Hey.
Hey, Luna.
You won't leave me, like...
You won't leave me, right?
Like, that bitch.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I guess I'll leave you, though.
Never mind.
I guess I'll leave you instead.
That's right.
I do the leaving here.
I make my own destiny.
Which hero do you think you want to be?
Yeah, I break up with her.
That's fucking right.
I really want to play Adam.
I really do, but I don't think we can.
Man, I want to play Adam.
But, like, Adam is so bad against double support.
The seduction of Adam.
I'm going to do it.
I'm gonna pick Adam.
I'm gonna do it, and then we'll get yelled at.
I'm gonna do it.
Can I?
Can I have fun time?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm not gonna succumb to pressure.
I wanna play it.
Adam.
Where we defense?
Where we attack?
Ah, fuck.
Join the Adams family.
I'm gonna fly.
No, I'm a pussy.
Come.
I'm a pussy.
I'm a meta slave.
I can't do it.
I'm a coward, heavenly.
I'm a fucking coward.
I'm a slave to meta.
Please switch back to Adam now.
Badger has to think you hit the bitty Stinky thing.
I already walked over here.
Can't do it.
I'll do it on attack.
I won't be a coward then.
Don't worry.
I don't want to add him, but I don't want to throw.
My urge to not throw is greater than my urge to play add
him.
He is the perfect.
human being but my desire to not throw overcomes my desire
to play at him what is our
does that double oh no wait wait that might be double that
oh i should let the moonlight farm that okay Oh my god, it
is double dive.
He doesn't know where my res is.
That's right.
I almost forgot where my res is, too.
I can't blame him.
I also almost forgot where I put it.
I am the one that shoots back.
There we go.
All right, there you go Oh shit.
Whoa, whoa.
What does that fuck you want from me?
I'll just stay here What the fuck there is a Deadpool right
behind us guys There was a Deadpool right behind us guys.
Don't worry.
I got you girl.
He still doesn't know where my res is He's so confused Oh my
god, he's so confused He was like, I swear I saw a rocket
here earlier.
Oh my god.
Just kite it, you can't.
We are kiting it.
Can we look at that?
I'm a...
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
We have...
Invisible.
That's right.
I know how to shoot my gun.
Okay, I don't know about that, but that's fine.
It's all right.
He's trying, so he is.
He actually is.
He really wants me dead.
I want to wait here a little.
Because I think we'll be fine.
Okay, now I don't think we'll be fine.
Now I don't think so.
Now, now I don't think so.
This is a little bad, only because that was a lot of our
alts.
That was every alt.
There you go.
That was...
He's up top.
I can hear him.
There he is.
Goodbye.
There he was.
You good up there, Rocket?
Yes.
don't worry about me
famous last words but don't worry about me guys that's okay
this reds in the middle of the open is not gonna fuck us
over I Told you I told you don't worry about me
See I told you guys Jesus Christ Oh my god, the bien, the
bien
Oh shit Oh, that's awkward I'll catch you up.
T-play.
That's me.
Come on.
I'm almost there.
We're almost there.
I needed 99.
I was 99.
Just listen at 1%.
Just listen at 1% it's not really like lag.
It's this map that makes you lag really bad.
Didn't even need a up.
There we go.
I mean, I've been playing MRC all day.
I'm hyper- MRC?
Anything that comes across, I got you.
Holy shit.
I even know that's going on right now.
All right.
This is it.
I will bring peace to this universe.
I'm not throwing.
If my support dies, we lose.
This is it.
I have to play for my support.
Lots of subs from him, I think.
Cool.
It's time.
I want chicken out.
I believe.
I am.
Or at least I did.
The perfect human being.
There you go.
This is it.
Okay, I could accidentally throw and fly.
Try to fly across and die.
But I don't know.
I don't know if it's worth it.
I could technically try and do that and see if it works.
Holy shit!
Who cares?
Let's go!
Wee!
Oh, shit.
People are dead.
I told you.
It's just that easy.
We win on Adam.
I never punish the two seconds on Adam.
Adam obviously without Adam we wouldn't have clutched that
just that easy me does he play this game for a living all
right let's check it out is yeah there's no way oh my oh
what the fuck oh he's a coach okay okay I was gonna say that
guy's it's okay for I was gonna say there's no way but he's
a coach guys the guy's a coach he can't be in the silo it's
not about it's not about how he uses the mechanics it's how
he gives the information to other players as long as he's
knowledgeable about what is right that's all it matters
that's all that matters yeah those who can't do They teach.
I was going to say, I googled his name, and I pulled up a
Wikipedia, and I was about to be like, oh, no.
How did you get here?
Yeah, do as I say, not as I do.
He coaches so that his players can carry.
That's all he needs.
that are back to back to crash the more e-dates all right
any new couples there's so many people that are just alone
it's so sad hello i'm gonna steal your date um um um um um
um um
Um, but, um, look, I even have, like, a third Jeff, and I
don't know if I like this view or not.
I don't know yet.
Whoa.
Well, goodbye, Jeff.
Um, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Do not the shark.
Why is the shark not sitting down with me?
Come on.
Come on, Jeff.
why am i looking up why was he on top of me huh you're gonna
ask the real questions here why was he on top of me i don't
know what does it look like oh my god go venom go paper
thank you for the hundred biddies thank you thank you
uh midney thank you this hundred Finis, thank you, thank
you.
Consider this leftovers of my red pocket.
Thank you!
Do you think you want to be here?
Thank you so much.
Alright.
What I want to play...
Okay.
I'll let you enjoy, Adam.
This is a comp right there.
I'll be doing a lot of healing, though.
I think, like, if I could play Adam, who gets the most... I
guess Cloak is...
the most healing output because of the right click it's
actually john adam what would it take for a dps game for me
to swap accounts swapping to a bronze account i do have i do
have an account that's bronze slash silver i will not insert
these games hyper thank you for the hundred videos
It's only the reason why it's bronze silver is because I
haven't played on it for a while It's like super decayed
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump Bump, bump You'll need a top
notch team to win this one
All right, this is a very interesting comp Oh, that Adam is
braver than me He did what I was too much of a coward to do
He did what I was too much of a cow He was so confident No
decay I meant like placement decay Like if you don't do
placements Several seasons in a row Like you're like It goes
to like silver slash bronze
Like I have an account That I haven't touched in like
several seasons placement is like at like if I get on it
it'll be on like silver slash bronze last time I checked
just because I like that because it was before placement so
it's like decayed all the way down
great thank you for the twitch prize thank you thank you all
right here we go I haven't played invas in so long I just
don't think invas is good anymore I find her like I first
didn't think like I think everyone's just so used to playing
invas because we've been playing in this for so fucking long
that no one wants to even though she's not good people are
still playing her this is a terrible comp by the way our
comp is fucking terrible and then my other healer is trying
to flank like like i don't know what the plan oh my god i
don't know what the plan is but it's not that my my only
other healer wants to flank Like, it's fucking crazy.
Alright, here we go.
I don't have much.
Oh my god, we did it.
Just never stop holding.
Left click, that's the plan.
There you go.
You need heals, though.
A little bit of heals.
I could technically use this aggressively, but also that i
don't know what's going on my team right now like a little
worried okay oh my god okay it's fine my team
i can stay up here okay we did not need all of that but
that's cool we definitely i hear i hear wet feet I hear the
sound of webbed feet and they more is right behind us.
Hello.
I have to use this for myself.
He's by himself.
Like, I don't...
I'm sorry.
Did we kill them the more?
I don't even...
Oh.
I don't know if we killed him or not.
Holy shit.
shit that is not enough heals that is absolutely not enough
heals for any of this
holy all right
i swear i i am trying to i am not let go of left click in so
long i will say
i will say that i mean we could.
Oh.
There we go.
I'm leaving.
All right, that's cool.
That's not longer cool.
That's no longer cool.
I do think more heals would definitely help us right now.
It's no longer cool, guys.
I I'm try oh my god I really am trying to keep you up right
now I really have
holy shit all right here we go here we go
hello there is a rocket here If we'd like to kill him.
Oh, never mind.
Fuck him, I'll guess.
Where's the...
Where's the truck?
There it is.
I was like, where did it go?
Please.
You guys are all scaring me right now.
You guys really are all scaring me right now.
I have not let go of left click, please.
Oh my god.
Oh yes!
Double support up!
No longer.
Not a great time right.
Not a good time for me right now.
Not...
Please just walk up a little...
Wait, where is my...
Why did I not get res?
But he self-rested himself.
Why did I not get self-rest?
I was next to the car.
I'm so confused.
No, if he reses himself, and he'll still have his ult.
Yeah, but like he resed himself, so that's why I was so
confused.
It should still work.
If he's still alive He sounded yeah, I was gonna say was he
not in the next to the our point like where was he?
Oh, yeah, no, he's fucking dead like I'm sorry like I can't
save that That's a little too far
I'm gonna be here Oh,
I didn't hit that.
All right, let's hope that everybody...
Goodbye.
Wait, for who?
For...
Oh, for...
Okay, he's dead.
I was gonna say...
for who's though oh my god that's so unlucky that's so
unlucky I didn't know where the strange was okay our Adam
for someone who is Lord on Adam very questionable very very
questionable for someone who is Lord on Adam and someone
who's clearly wants to force Adam.
Oh, God.
No!
Keep forgetting.
I need it.
I really need to be on cloak for him.
I really, I really need to be on cloak for him.
I keep forgetting to do it.
Oh, my God.
It's just not reflex for me, and that's an issue.
It's fine.
I'm going to go rock it now.
I have to go rock it.
now and just hope the guy bro he's just getting chased
non-stop holy shit oh my god I swear I swear to God you
better be getting these reses though oh it Doesn't matter
No, that was a questionable all for me.
I will I will say that I always it's just not in my head to
be on cloak right now Because I got away too many I got way
too comfortable not getting punished Because like I don't
play as much anymore So like in this elo people do not
punish you so I get way too comfortable with that
It's like the first time I ever got punished for not being
on cloak for him.
No, but he didn't do it.
He didn't do it.
He didn't do it at the moment.
I would.
I had time to actually fade.
That's the thing.
I have time to actually fade.
But I didn't do it.
just like whatever it's all i that is so i'm sorry but like
it's so embarrassing that like if that is all he plays and
that's it doesn't seem as i will say his adam he's not he's
not getting the dps like he's not playing him the way that
an adam one trick would be playing and then the thing is
look this is why i hate triple support because it's like
when we need it my dps players don't want to swap off
because they're like they're like i'm doing enough to like
not swap you know so it's like it's very annoying Why would
you...
Wait.
Okay.
He didn't instinctually snap.
He snapped when I died.
God damn this out of it.
You're supposed to snap the moment you...
The moment you...
get hit, but he didn't do that.
Where the fuck?
Oh my god.
I hope he res.
He has to res.
Why is he...
No!
Oh man, it's not worth it.
It's not worth it to help now.
Oh, and the thing is, we know we need a triple support
because we're forcing Adam, but our two DPS don't want to
swap off at...
Swap to a support.
Yeah.
I mean, now you see how bad your reses are?
Yeah, okay, there we go.
There we go.
Now, now we're doing it.
Thank God.
Okay.
All right.
Now we have more heals.
We actually have more heals.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
But it was our tank.
It was our...
Okay.
It was our tank, though.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, my God.
I'm not on cloak.
It's fine.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
I would have died regardless.
Oh, man.
I wish I had an Adam risk.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
The thing is, it should not be our...
It shouldn't be our tank that's swapping to...
That's swapping to third support.
It always has...
Because third support doesn't do anything.
It doesn't do anything for triple.
It has to be...
I mean third support doesn't do anything if it's double
tank.
It has to be the DPS.
Because you run triple support with two tanks.
Because then you can't farm support else in time.
You have to run two tanks to farm support all the...
What the fuck?
What happened to the...
Okay, I was gonna just sit.
I thought I saw...
Maybe that's why he's hard stuck in this E though, by
forcing Adam.
Like at least you could technically force Adam by asking for
triple support.
Or just play with... do a way with a support player so you
can always have triple support.
That's the...
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
That's good.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Our three supports died!
Including me!
Oh my god.
And our Adam.
Our Adam didn't have second res.
.
It's fine.
I use fade.
I fucking use fade.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god, I'm on point.
I'm on point.
Please, please, please, please get on point!
Come on.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
we actually totally we should not have won that but I played
some I did some fucked up shit too I made a lot of mistakes
there I made I made a lot of mistakes I will say but my
everybody made mistakes too thank God thank God thank God I
wasn't the only one that made mistakes
Yeah.
This is really bad for us, though, in general.
I just don't know where that is.
Oh my god.
Oh, he must have been 100 charge.
I was like, how did I die?
He must have been 100 charge.
They hit a checkpoint.
Now it might be in their time to stop battling time to
shine.
Hmm.
He must have been 100 charged for that.
There's no way.
I did not think I was going to get ultra fucking hit there.
I was not expecting that.
That's why I, like, ego did a little.
Because I was like, I should be fine, right?
I was not fine.
Unfortunately, I was not fine.
i really would like to push up can we we're laying them okay
what i don't like right now is that we are letting them push
up a lot yeah i mean that's fine that's fine but let's just
hope our atom doesn't die i'm gonna hope to god never mind
Okay, I don't know if the mag has alt though, which is what
I'm afraid of.
I hope he's okay.
All right.
Can we support alt?
Here we go.
All right.
Oh my god Who's in it?
Fucking knew it I knew it I knew you were in there Oh fuck
Okay Oh we win We won Okay We won That's fine That was like
my worst Clok gameplay ever But like We won Like Thank god
It doesn't matter.
We still got it.
A win's a win.
Adam, somehow this trash ad just keeps going higher.
Stop it.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Not like we had a triple support.
This guy, it's not like we had to go triple support to
fucking actually do it.
thing he is so perfect yeah all the res is fucking sucked
dude not even a good fucking res we had the force triple oh
my god I'm just glad no bro he had the it was just it was
not it he was just not it i don't mind like i think it just
play adam when we have triple support you can force adam all
you want on triple or like just play with someone
just play with another support player and then you'll always
you'll always be able to do do adam
or how long might you name me this would be an lg we'll see
how i feel if the game is either really fucking bad that it
turns into lg we'll see we'll see how i feel
i don't um oh when we're getting flanked luna meta um you
can be the change you want to be flank luna actually works
but you just have that you just gotta be assured like Your
team's just gonna yell at you all the time.
But she, surprisingly, works very well.
Thank God.
Thank God my DPS was like, you know what?
I'm gonna suck up my ego.
I'm gonna do it.
Thank God.
Thank God my DPS was just like, fuck this.
Yeah, I heard the...
I really think...
I think like...
Overwatch is a harder game.
now that's why i personally feel as a support player because
your your healing is not like a guaranteed um like get out
of jail free card now who am i gonna banish from the match
playing rivals basically spoiled me so much because i can i
heal so much and my ult builds up so fast that like i don't
have as much fear when i play over when versus overwatch
Overwatch.
Overwatch on support is so hard to play now.
Because your healing doesn't actually, your healing is like
a lot lower than what I was used to when I first started
playing Overwatch.
And it's like, and you have to do more damage.
You have to actually balance your DPS and your support.
You can't heal, but unsupport and get away with it.
Oh my god, now I have to play with it, Jeff.
Yeah.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Oh, you know what?
We'll do Mantis.
Oh my, I will be the change I want to be.
Could you do Mantis?
God damn it.
I'm a pussy.
I'm a cowie.
They asked nicely, okay?
They asked nicely.
That will unfortunately not be the change I want to be.
They did not say please.
They did not slur at me, though, and that's considered nice
in Rivals.
Guys, you have to remember, this is Marvel Rivals.
They didn't slur at me.
So at that point, I consider it nice.
I consider that a nice request.
Yeah, asking for please is too much, guys.
Not in my arrivals.
Look, you have to expect the bare minimum.
Them hitting the bare minimum is like a goal.
Being nice to competitors, not being called a racial slur.
Or any type of slur in general.
oh my god there's a spot and we have oh
i thought i predicted the shield run what the already i'm
leaving good bye
holy shit's one oh my god please try going up there you go
he's actually one go left go
In the room.
Look alone, one point.
Oh!
Alright, let's be over here instead.
Oh, and then let's be here now.
Oh my god, I wish I knew I would have.
Please, he's so low!
I don't want it.
I got scared.
oh my god where is it oh i
am trying my best to heal right now
please anybody please he's so low oh my god he walked away
from me that's good he walked away from me that's good all
right yeah i know the stone protect that's why i went here
Oh, it's a...
I even forgot we had a deer pool.
Make the skinny Davis with me?
I'm not old.
Alright, here we go.
Nothing.
But that's okay.
You don't need anything for that.
Oh, backing out.
Backing out.
Well, he is so fucking dead.
I'm backing out fully.
Sometimes you just gotta.
Shit, I'll damage boost Jeff, actually.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
There we go.
Help him.
Help him!
I have to go last, though.
When it comes to up.
All right Well, I don't really want to be here.
Oh, what oh yeah, I was gonna say we're Oh my god, you know
who else is please somebody kill this There you go How is
our venom still alive though?
That's crazy Almost there I'll go last I'll go last going
right.
Okay, I'll go first dead it should be me last but there we
go there we go because i have oh yep yep you saw that i yeah
i know i had a feeling it was gonna do that i had a feeling
yeah i was like no No.
Oh god.
Oh god!
Please,
he's still alive!
I'm literally like juggling.
I'm kiting as much as I can.
Wait.
I swear to God, I saw... Oh, there she is.
How's that?
Did I see that?
I tried to jump somewhere.
He does have a lot, though.
Oh, yeah, no.
He's fucking dead.
I was gonna say, yep, goodbye.
Goodbye.
That thing has all, and I don't want to be there.
I really don't want to be there.
Oh, shit!
Yep.
I told you!
That was a really bad ult, though, but, like, you know.
It's very easy to predict.
Oh my god, that's stupid.
Oh, nice, nice, that's a good pull.
Nope.
Hope it wasn't, like, close to me or anything.
Oh.
No, you're so close.
There we go.
Catch the car, catch the car.
Hello.
Oh, um...
Nice.
Yay!
Push it, push it, push it, push it!
He has no bubble.
I would be like...
All right, we can back up, we can back up.
Yeah, I was gonna say, all right, Venom, Venom might be
dead.
I really don't feel confident about our fantastic living
right now.
Nice!
He still is!
Let's go, let's go!
Oh, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, I'm here.
I'm here for you guys.
I'm here.
I'm here, guys.
Do not worry.
Nice.
The current score is 3, 2, 0.
Yes!
Triple support.
Oh, I hate.
Oh, triple support.
Now they're gonna run triple because we made triple work.
This is the cycle I hate because they see triple working and
then they're gonna be like, we gotta run triple now.
And then we continue the cycle.
Look just you wait We're going to watch them pull up with
triple support Because they're like Look at the steam We
need to go triple to count on this And then the game won't
be as fun anymore It's fun right now sort of Because we're
winning And they can't counter it So it's working out But
then Then they're going to pull out the triple And then it's
going to be an alt rotation of hell.
It's not support damage.
Just need a nerf support heals.
That's it.
They just need a nerf support heals.
That's literally what they have to do.
And everything should be fine.
There's my Phoenix.
I should be.
I can't even damage booster.
Oh, that didn't hit anybody.
I'm surprised.
I'm surprised that didn't hit anybody.
Oh, mag one, mag one, mag literally one.
There's more than one person that's one over there.
Yeah, he is definitely not one anymore.
Oh, no!
Oh, he's alive.
I'm going to give Jeff the damage boost, too, just because
he's just piercing, and piercing is so strong.
What the fuck?
He just got cut.
We just got cut.
Oh, my God.
That was such a good fade, though.
That was actually a really good fade that he did.
Oh, my God.
Really?
How did he see me?
Oh, my.
What?
He wasn't even trying to get me.
He actually wasn't trying to get me there.
On my way.
That's crazy.
He wasn't trying to get me in fucking accidentally.
Hardest tall point, I'm poorly.
I am trying.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
He fucked up.
He hit his head.
That's actually so...
good he
actually hit his head he got fucked over because of it thing
one thing one oh my god he hit his head stupid oh I thought
that was my bad but he's stupid he actually hit his head
that.
There you go.
I'm just going to do this so our team can live through that.
I had to do that.
Oh my god, he got, that was literally the body block of hell
right there.
I don't know if you saw that.
That body block was actually so...
Oh, no.
That's fine.
My other two supports are still alive.
See that?
I think they finally swapped the triple.
It only took them, like, four minutes.
I do not remember seeing a Luna before.
They finally went triple support.
It really took them a very long time to do it, though.
all right that's fine that is not fine though that is not oh
no no and the cycle continues oh no Oh
Yeah, it's lost you is lost the porn is lost back up Um, she
got pulled out she got pulled out into a wolf from the wolf
You guys just sit back and look pretty okay.
I got the rest What what did he say not doing anything but
can't see my old and I fucking hate him I didn't even hear
what he said
I'm pretty sure he has.
Oh my god.
The only issue is that...
You're alive!
There we go.
It was worth it.
It was so worth it.
We saved our venom!
Who were the change?
Okay, now I gotta let my other support heal.
I'm just gonna damage boost.
Either just damage boosted hope.
Let them push, I have ult.
Oh, there is his ult too.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What is going on?
Only 60 seconds left.
There we go.
He doesn't know where I am, technically.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I peaked.
I was like, oh, he doesn't know where I am.
And then I was like, okay, it's safe now.
It was not safe.
I knew he had all two.
I was like, what is he gonna do?
and kill me he tried and killed me guys oh my god there you
go we didn't just win off this never mind never mind never
mind i back up
that's right he has all up too but i'm on high ground he
can't get me up here yeah see that predicted fucking proof
Get predicted.
Clobbered is.
Look at that.
That's all I needed to do.
See?
Knowing what their ulces helps me there.
Except for whenever the Wolverine ults me.
The clobbering...
To be sure, he was not winning with that clobbered.
He was like, hell merry.
That was a hell merry clobber right there.
All right.
Do we end with triple support?
That's the question.
Do we end the game with triple support?
Is that something we want to do?
Or do we do one more game?
End with a win?
You're right, guys.
But the win streak.
I'm going to end with a win.
Only you could stop the triple support.
One more?
Oh my god.
You guys know.
You guys know I'm easily invincible.
I'm easily tempted.
Alright, one more.
One more.
We end on a loss.
How about that?
We end on a... One more.
One more.
I got one, God.
Because this is the game where we end.
Where we lose.
You guys know...
It's so easy to manipulate.
me we erin on a loss oh wait they're on a date oh they're on
a date oh it's oh oh oh my god oh oh hey spider-man no one
come with me on this come on spider-man no no come on no no
spider-man leave him sit with me come on spider-man come on
hey guys whoa got come on spider-man you know spider-man
come on pick me i'm the that's right come on come over here
i'm over here spider-man oh it's okay we can make him
jealous spider-man i'm right here spider-man we can make him
jealous I can be a better Venom for you.
I can be a better Venom.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright.
Let's see.
You can't be someone's rebound.
Alright, this is not...
Oh, wait.
gambit i'm banning loki i'm gonna ban loki we're running
gambit i'm not playing loki for you i am not going through
that i'm not going through that hella okay
i can't even be his rebound
oh gambit got banned thank god all right don't have to worry
about that no more all right you can bet whatever you want
now You can ban whatever the fuck you are.
Guys, they got a one above all blade in the enemy team who's
starting right now.
Yeah, shut up, man.
Freaking nerd.
Yeah, at least finish my sentence with.
Ah, bro.
Smurfing.
So if I put it inside you, would I be the bad guy?
Yeah, yeah, all quiet now, huh?
Damn.
Poor villain.
I'm not judging.
bro so like why'd you hover over gambit right and then
whenever he got banned you instantly went to dps i don't i'm
not playing heels bro i'm only playing i'm only playing
gambit what what the fuck type what is that what is that so
boring playing heels all right brad all right brad guys i'm
ready i'm ready for this to be my last game guys no no no no
no no bro you're good bro don't worry I didn't want to end
on a lost guy.
Guys, I did say this won't be the game where we lose.
Yeah, genuinely.
It's my alt account, bro.
Have fun, bro.
We're going your alt account too, bro.
We don't go.
Oh, no.
Please.
This is your alt account.
Hey, you're tough, bro.
You're tough, bro.
Thank you, bro.
Thank you.
This feels like a great last game, everybody.
Let's go.
Let's go!
Yeah, you see when that guy was like, can you play Mathis?
Look, this is I told you the bare minimum at the bare
minimum Of them not slurring at me is my bare minimum
That's what I'm saying I mean look at you though, look at
you though, like you're feeling like I had to I had to I
mean you're legit feeling for me You're a bitch, bro, that's
what you are I'm a 40-year-old.
Who's helping you?
There we go.
All right, we lived somehow.
We...
Okay.
We won the fight um i won that team fight it looked to be
fair it really looked very hopeless there i am just as
surprised as all of you guys that fight looked like nothing
was gonna at work it looked like very hopeless
what's up okay our daredevil ego does shit out of I don't
know why our daredevil was egoing so hard there I I don't
know how
that worked I'm gonna be like you first why are you like why
are you like low key mid at there wait why are you low-key
milk than at Elsa, bro.
Oh, yo.
It is.
I'm back, bro.
I'm off of.
No, no, no.
I lost order, bro.
I lost order there.
You're right.
You're right, bro.
I lost order, bro.
I'm off.
I'll fall, bro.
You know, I took it back there.
Take everything.
She's taking everything.
Okay.
Hey, she ulted.
She ulted.
I were...
What?
Yeah, bro, I popped her for my spell.
What of it?
Oh yeah?
Yeah.
What?
I mean, like, bro, you have so much horror.
Thank you, bro.
I know.
Lost the shit.
Now I'm gonna get a kill.
What is going on?
I'm dead, bro.
Oh, that's unlucky Oh, that's also unlucky That's also
unlucky They didn't even let me leave That's also unlucky
They did use everything They did use everything Okay, they
used everything I'm tired, boss I'm tired Okay, I won't be
surprised Of half of these players are Are in high school
Like Like, I legitimately will not be surprised.
It really does feel like I'm playing with a bunch of high
schoolers right now.
Like, last game of the day before they have to go to sleep.
What the fuck?
how are you dying bro you just like stay closer to me like i
don't know don't talk a freaking rocket like that bro
all right guys can i play like dps i feel like i'm at like
college night high school night right now there's a doctor
rocket got you i forgot we had an angela i'm not gonna lie
Like, yo, hey, I don't even know we had an angel.
It's got my back until I still, until I start dying more.
It's like last game before they gotta go to class tomorrow.
Oh my god.
No, but you should know magnetism doesn't work on
supercooled materials.
Guess what I can do?
The moment I make one mistake, I think the guy is...
will start slurring at me he might have defended me now but
guys that can turn around so easily you have no idea how
fast i could turn around that's why my bunny hogs better
than yours bro i mean bro like that's what you are
god bro he needs to get a job bro not me
Oh.
Hey, kill her.
Oh, we killed her.
All right.
No, no, no.
Angela, why are we stealing my kills?
What?
Enough for jobs?
That's a good...
Whoa.
Hey.
That's a good question, honestly.
That is a very good question.
I am...
I also would like to know.
You guys, I'm about to let the devil out.
Alright, here we go.
Oh.
Like, we're like, what are we doing, bro?
No, no, because what are you gonna do with that?
Like, what are we doing?
Go ahead, Rocket, keep me up.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm not my oldest guy.
My god bro.
Luna, you're not on the same temple as me bro.
Oh, shut up bro.
Go heal me!
I'm dead bro.
I'm just feet under.
What do you want me to do?
My god.
Keep going.
Bro, bro, bro, bro, bro.
You know what are you doing bro?
Yo, I'm not even, I don't even hold you bro.
I don't even heal bro.
I only have AK heals bro.
You got me bro.
You caught me bro.
I'm not actually healing bro.
I got what's going on what is going on?
what the fuck is going on right now?
well let's hope do you think our Luna is gonna hey I got
this don't worry I got this get together go get them get
together guys yeah you're dead bro I got you I got you Oh, I
don't know if he's got him.
Oh, my God.
Where are you, bro?
What do you mean?
I'm next to you!
Oh, my God.
Where are you, bro, as I'm next to him?
Holy shit.
There's no way he said that.
He's like, where are you as I'm right next to him?
Holy fuck.
My God, good shit, man.
Shit, good shit, bro.
I got this.
That's one, that's one down.
Okay, that's fine.
The Spider-Man has- I'm not gonna lie, I don't feel like you
and you.
Hey, good luck though.
You're on your own.
Yeah, I'm gonna let the devil out.
I'm a 1v6.
Hit me up!
I don't think he gets them.
I got you rocket don't worry oh my god he actually got me
I'm dead bro oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god I'm
here I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm actually okay
I'm we won we won whatever this match is oh never mind never
mind I spoke too soon I spoke too soon i i actually i'm here
i'm here i'm here i'm here oh my god we oh my god oh my god
what this game oh my god bro hey elsa elsa you are butt at
the game bro delete the game rocket bro i carried you on my
bag uh angela bro i don't know another epic victory hey
blaze it
Bro, okay, he's like, I'm DPSing and he has 2.5k damage He
had 2.5k damage for a guy that was like, yeah, I'm DPSing,
I'm not.
That's, all right, all right, let's, uh, wait, did we have,
of Lucky Zeal?
Wait, Lucky Zeal was on the enemy team?
Bro, no.
Bro, I think he'd be so fucking mad if he knew exactly how
my team was playing.
Yeah, he was the Spider-Man.
He was, yeah.
I don't think he'd be happy if He'd fucking know what my
team was fucking doing.
He was, he was, my team was not locked in.
I will say that.
Wait.
I think, do you know why I think my team actually won that
game?
Because they rather, they might hate each other, but they
don't want to lose the lucky zeal.
They might, they were like, We're not losing against him.
I, my team, my team truly was the team.
I think, I think I'll end it with that.
I think it's just going to go downhill after that.
The A was united.
I think, I think that is the sign, chat.
That is the sign that that will be the last game.
I don't think it can.
I don't, I, I, really don't want to know if i can get
further down there i don't
you're right negative negative with negative equals a
positive guys
two two negatives turn into a positive all right that i felt
like i could get lower but like i felt like we could hit
even more rock bottom um if we queue another that was a
Anyway, guys, I hope you guys enjoy this guerrilla stream,
this spontaneous stream.
Today, that was a nice session.
We managed to complete both our bounty sponsors in time and
not get punished like last time.
But tomorrow, I won't be streaming since this was the bonus
stream.
I do need to rest.
I need to take a little rest day.
So tomorrow will be my rest day.
my high schoolers had a had the wind that they needed before
they had to go to class tomorrow before that they wake up at
7 a.m or 6 a.m.
hit the class tomorrow but we guys have fun watching chat um
surprisingly the weekend cues were not as cursed as i
thought i actually went positive today which is always a
plus uh which is always nice you know we only had oh we had
one loss today fucked up thing with this was pretty messed
up but we two four six seven we were our record was uh six
one that's pretty neat not bad yeah actually had a nice
climb today anyway guys um as always oh wait before i leave
you guys want to check me on other platforms uh please check
me on youtube that's where i usually stream um um that's my
main platform i do guerrilla stuff i do spontaneous streams
on twitch uh well uh but you all know whenever i stream on
twitch please feel free to follow me on twitter because
that's where i tweet out whenever i stream on twitch uh for
the non-schedule stuff um what else i want to support me if
you other means please feel free to buy my merch i do have a
new music video out right now um new cover song out right
now uh so yeah stream if you guys want to check out my
singing check out my new music video um and you don't want
check out my support maybe other means feel free to check
out my merch store we do have several drops going on right
now the anniversary the watson plush that's going on with my
collaboration with apex legends um that has uh the
anniversary stuff the watson stuff and the lunar new year
drops are all limited uh so make sure to grab some of those
if you guys want something to commemorate um special
important times uh in my career this is the time to get it
before the end of the month uh not this month by the way uh
it's like a one month pre-order period so uh i think you
have like how many days left let me check uh but but but you
choose watson watson plus you have 15 days left so two weeks
left uh the pre-orders uh make sure to grab the apex skins
because there's 15 days left to grab the watson apex skin uh
the dokey watson skin i also put me on other means there's
still i have a game yourself's code dokeybird um a hi uh
hiate stuff for PC case or heat caps or desk mats and EA
code.
You don't want to purchase anything on Apex.
I do have an EA code and a Stokeybird as well.
Anyway, guys, I think that's everything to shill for.
And that's everything.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause, check, yeah, but
move around to get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it.
Oh, yeah, and an MSI code as well.
This is the monitor I use currently.
I have 500 hertz for it.
I really highly recommend it because it really does help
improve my gameplay.
As always, everybody, as always, everybody, stay hydrated,
posture check, get up and move around to get that blood
flowing.
And instead of for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.